make a damn schedule and stick to it he
said what's the rule with the schedule
it's not a bloody prison that's the
first thing that people do wrong they
say well I don't like to have follow a
schedule well what kind of schedule are
you setting up well I have to do this
then I have to do this then I have to do
this you know and then I just go play
video games because who wants to do all
these things that I have to do it's like
wrong set the damn schedule up so that
you have the day you want that's the
trick it's like okay I've got tomorrow
if I was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day I could have
practically speaking what would it look
like well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that then at the beginning of the
day right because that's a stupid day if
you have a bunch of those in a row you
just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like sorry that's just not a good
strategy it's a bad strategy hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I quit I'm
a business partner I struggle to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Jordan Peterson
Joy
maybe twenty percent of your day has to
be responsibility and obligation or
maybe it's more than that depending on
how far behind you are but even that you
can you can ask yourself okay well I've
got these responsibilities I have to
schedule the damn things in what's the
right ratio of responsibility to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you got
to work tomorrow
okay so I want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
going to do for me
that makes it likely that I'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you do an hour of of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes I don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life and and that's how
you make the schedule it's like and then
you look at the day and you think well
if I had that day that'd be good great
you know and you you're useless and
horrible so you'll probably only hit it
with about 70 percent accuracy but that
beats the hell out of zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
the next week or 50 and a half percent
for God's sake or because you're you're
going to hit that position where things
start to loop back positively and spiral
you upward make a damn plan and make one
you want like don't make a plan that is
what you should do even though it will
be what you should do make a plan that
outlines the future so that you could
sit back and say look if I had that
future then all the horrible things that
are going to happen to me are going to
be worthwhile
that's what you want so you want to
think this game is worth playing despite
its tragedy that's what you've got in
life enough meaning to serve as an
antidote to tragedy all right now and
then you generate a strategy and then
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious industrious is
discipline yourself and so what do you
do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time I would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because I've
got more and more disciplined like get
up early in the morning and get your
things done man you learn to get up at
six in the morning and you'll be one
deadly creature especially if you can
get to work you'll have half your damn
day done by the time other people haul
their sorry asses out of bed and so
that's a massive massive Advantage look
Will Ferrell Warren Farrell not the
comedian Warren Farrell the author he
outlined data in why men earn more which
is a book I would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40 percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them Works an extra 10 percent
it's not much well how often is that
person going to be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss it's like you're going to look at
the 10 people and you're going to think
oh that guy's always here like 45
minutes early it's like why don't we
give him the promotion obviously right
so these tie these small edges that you
can manage like that work an extra ten
percent or extra 13 have
non-proportional payoffs that's part of
the Pareto distribution
so get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses I'm too tired in the morning
I don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
Google Calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at Bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
it's also helps you plan what you want
to do so I could say well layout your
damn calendar
and design the days you would like to
have that's what your calendars have is
for so you can put in all sorts of
things in there you want to do and that
would be good for you and that's a
really good a really good way to start
being more industrious make a plan you
need a plan for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour all of that all of that I make
lists constantly of what I have to do
and they're like daily weekly monthly
yearly right now I can't look out more
than about six months you know because
my life is too complicated and chaotic
but but you need a vision of who you
could be what character you could have
three to five years out you can't go
much farther than that because life is
too unpredictable I think to make Vision
that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too too much chance associated
with it to spend a lot of time on maybe
you can stretch it to five years and in
rare cases you can have a 10-year goal
but it has to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down and what because what are
you going to do you're going to stumble
around and get get what you need you're
going to stumble around and be useful to
other people and it's useful to be
useful to other people you know they
want to work with you then they want to
do things with you they want to have you
around they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer then you're going to be
bitter and then you're going to be cruel
so that's a bit that's hell that's a bad
outcome so unless you want that don't
aim for it and or or aim for the
opposite because that's how you get out
of it part of the reason that people go
watch anti-heroes and villains is
because there's a part of them crying
out for the incorporation of the monster
within them which is what gives them
strength of character and self-respect
because it's impossible to respect
yourself until you grow teeth and if you
grow teeth then you realize that you're
somewhat dangerous and or maybe somewhat
seriously dangerous and then you might
be more willing to demand that you treat
yourself with respect and other people
do the same thing and so that doesn't
mean that being cruel is better than not
being cruel what it means is that being
able to be cruel and then not being
cruel is better than not being able to
be cruel because in the first case
you're nothing but weak and naive and in
the second case you're dangerous but you
have it under control and you know a lot
of martial arts concentrate on exactly
that as part of their philosophy of
training it's like we're not training
you to fight we're training you to be
peaceful and awake and avoid fights but
if you happen to have to get in one
and I guess the philosophy also is is
that if you're competent
at fighting that actually decreases the
probability that you're going to have to
fight because when someone pushes you
you'll be able to respond with
confidence and with any luck and this is
certainly the case with bullies with any
luck a reasonable show of confidence
which is very much equivalent to a show
of dominance is going to be enough to
make the bully back off and so the
strength that you develop in your
monstrousness is actually the best
guarantee of peace there's this old
story in King Arthur where the knights
go off to look for the Holy Grail
which is either the cup that Christ
drank out of it the last supper or the
cup into which the blood that gushed
from his side was poured when he was
crucified the stories vary but it's it's
basically a holy object like the Phoenix
in some sense that's representation a
representation of transformation so it's
a it's an ideal and so King Arthur's
knights who sit at a round table because
they're all roughly equal go off to find
the most valuable thing and they and
where do you look for the most valuable
thing when you don't know where it is
well each of the knights looks at the
forests surrounding the castle and
enters the forest at the point that
looks darkest to him
and that's a good thing to understand
because the gateway to wisdom and the
gateway to the development of
Personality which is exactly the same
thing is precisely through the porthole
portal that you do not want to climb
through and the reason for that's
actually quite technical this is a union
presupposition too is that well there's
a bunch of things about you that are
underdeveloped and a lot of those things
are because they're things you've
avoided looking at because you don't
want to look at them and there's parts
of you you've avoided developing because
it's hard for you to develop those parts
and so it's it's by virtual necessity
that what you need is where you don't
want to look because that's where you've
kept it and so and that's why there's
you know an idiosyncratic element of it
for everyone your particular place of
Enlightenment and terror is not going to
be the same as yours except that they're
both places of Enlightenment and Terror
so they're equivalent at one level of
analysis and and different and another
so anyways back to fiction and and and
and what it does it it distills truth
and it it produces characters that are
Composites and the more they become
Composites the more they approximate a
mythological character
and so they become more and more
universally true and more and more
approximating religious deities but the
problem with that is they become more
and more distant from individual
experience and so with literature
there's this very tight
line where you need to make the
character more than merely human but not
so much of a God that you know one of
the things that happened to Superman in
the 1980s Superman started out he's got
a Heavenly set of parents but by the way
in an Earthly set of parents and he's an
orphan like Harry Potter very common
theme is that when Superman first
emerged he could only jump over
buildings you know and maybe he could
stop a locomotive but by the time the
1980s rolled around like he could juggle
planets and you know swallow hydrogen
bombs and you know he could do anything
well people stop buying the Superman
comics because how interesting is that
it's like something horrible happens and
Superman deals with it and and something
else horrible happens and Superman deals
with it and it's like that's
dull he turned into such an archetype he
was basically the omniscient omnipresent
um
I'm omnipotent God and that's no fun
it's like God wins and then God wins
again and then again God wins and you
know so then they had to weaken him in
different ways with Kryptonite you know
so green Kryptonite kind of made him
sick and read Kryptonite I think kind of
mutated him if I remember correctly and
anyways they had to introduce flaws into
his character so that there could be
some damn plot and not something to
think about you know there's a deep
existential lesson in that in that
your being is limited and and flawed and
fragile you're like the genie which is
genius in the little tiny
in the little tiny uh lamp you know this
immense potential but constrained in
this tiny little living space as Robin
Williams said when he played the genie
in Aladdin but the fact that you have
limitations
means that the plot of your life is the
overcoming of those limitations and that
if you didn't have limitations well
there wouldn't be a plot and maybe there
would be no life and so that's part of
the reason why perhaps you have to
accept the fact that you're flawed and
insufficient and and live with it and
consider it a precondition for being
it's at least a reasonable
it's a reasonable idea also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there you go and aim at something
it's like otherwise your life is
meaningless well what should you aim at
well I don't know well pick something
pick something aim at it as you move
toward it you'll get wiser than maybe
your aim will change that's okay but at
least it'll change in an informed way
it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension
see what happens
well that's exciting
and I think that's something that's open
for everyone
you can do that I shouldn't say that
because I don't believe that I think you
can find yourself in a situation that's
so dire that you don't there's no escape
from it
but that doesn't matter because this
still this is the hero myth might not be
the best we have might not always work
but it's still the best we have
and the fact that it might not work
doesn't mean we should throw it away
it's still the best we have
I mean everyone dies and so we fail in
some sense
the fact that a symphony ends doesn't
mean that it wasn't worth listening to
the more accurate a measure you take of
someone's political beliefs the more you
find that personality is what's
predicting them
and I think that's a reasonable thing to
think about because you know you have to
figure out ways of simplifying the world
right because you just can't do
everything
and so people are specialized they have
specialized niches that they occupy you
can think about them as social niches
like a niche is a place where your
particular skills would serve to
maintain you
and so if you're extroverted
you're going to look for a social Niche
because you like to be around people and
if you're introverted you're going to
spend much more time on your own and so
if you're an introverted person for
example you're going to want a job where
you're not selling and where you're not
surrounded by groups of people who are
making social demands on you all the
time because it'll wear you out whereas
if you're extroverted that's just
exactly what you want and so the
extrovert sees the world as a place of
social opportunity
and the introvert sees the world as a
place to retreat from and spend time
alone
and it turns out that
both of those modes of being are valid
the issue at least to some degree is
whether or not you're fortunate enough
to match your temperament with the
demands of the environment and I suppose
also whether you're fortunate enough so
that you're born in an era where there
actually is a niche for your particular
temperament because it isn't necessarily
the case that that will be the case
imagine that all of these temperamental
Dimensions vary because of evolutionary
pressure right so there's a distribution
of extroversion a normal distribution
most people are somewhere in the middle
and then as you go out towards the
extremes there are fewer and fewer
people
and what that means is that on average
across large spans of time
there have been environments that match
every single position on that
distribution with most most of the
environments matching the center because
otherwise we wouldn't have evolved that
way and so sometimes being really
extroverted is going to work well for
you in a minority of environments a
minority of niches and sometimes it's
just going to be a catastrophe I suspect
for example that if you live in a
tyrannical Society
where any sign of personally oriented
activity is likely to get you in trouble
that being extroverted and low in
neuroticism wouldn't be a very good idea
because you're going to be mouthy and
happy and saying a lot of things unable
to keep your thoughts to yourself and
you're going to be relatively Fearless
now I don't know that for sure because
we haven't done the studies that
precisely match temperamental proclivity
to environmental demand but you get what
I mean
you look where you think it's important
to look
so I'll say that again you look where
you think it's important to look and
that means that well a hierarchy of
importance is no different than a
hierarchy of value they're the same
thing a hierarchy of priority is the
same as a hierarchy of value and a
hierarchy of priority and a hierarchy
value and an ethic are all the same
thing right because you're going to look
at what you believe to be of cardinal
importance
otherwise you look well if you're
talking to someone and you look at their
feet
that's not going to be going very well
right first of all they're not going to
be very impressed with you because they
actually want you to look at their eyes
and that's because we communicate value
with our eyes and we do that directly
our eyes have even evolved to do that
our eyes have whites around the iris so
that you can see where people Point them
because it's that important to know what
people think is important we see the
world through a structure of value
and I think that a huge part of that
structure of value is actually derived
from the entire set of texts and their
interrelationship that have the biblical
Corpus at their base and so it seems to
me that you I think you can make a
pretty damn strong case
maybe on scientific grounds that you
can't see the world except through the
lens of the Bible
like literally you actually can't see it
now if it's not the Bible it might be
some other Corpus of texts but it might
be it isn't
and if it was well is it going to be a
corpus of text that we share because if
it isn't then we can't share our
perceptions and our values and if we
can't share those then we fight those
are the options right we either
stabilize our hierarchies of value in
some way that we agree upon mutually or
we fight that's or we're unbelievably
chaotic and confused and that'll just
produce fighting in any case and so
we have this structure of texts built
from the bottom up it's predicated on
the biblical narratives
and the texts exist in relationship to
those underlying narratives and derive a
fair bit of their meaning from the
meaning of the underlying narratives and
and vice versa you know
um
and so then the biblical is it possible
that biblical truth is the sort of truth
that is the precondition for truth
right because you think well it's
religious people make the claim people
of the Bible make the claim the Bible is
true well there's all sorts of different
kinds of truth that's that's an
interesting claim but it's not very
elaborated it's it's insufficient
um and you know often what happens to
Christians when they debate skilled
atheists like Richard Dawkins as they
treat the Bible like it's a scientific
theory and Dawkins just mops the floor
with them because it's actually not a
scientific theory compared to scientific
theories and so as soon as you go there
well it's like a scientific theory it's
like no it's not it's not and so does
that mean it's not true well it means
that if the only thing you think is true
is a scientific theory
but I don't think that you can practice
science except within an ethical
framework that's not in itself science
and so it's possible that there is a
deeper truth than the scientific truth
which is the ethic that has to be their
a priority before you can even begin to
do science you should treat yourself
like you're someone responsible for
helping and the first question is well
why don't you and the answer is
well there's a lot wrong with you
you know and it's hard to
exercise enough love
and Care in a deep and non-naive way to
care properly for something like that
it's an encouragement
to assume to act out the proposition
that even if life is as difficult
as it seems to be and if you're as
vulnerable and weak in a fundamental
sense as you definitely are and
characterized by this terrible
propensity for the infliction of
voluntary suffering on yourself and
others and that destructive tendency
that there's still something within you
that's so remarkable and so
aligned with
with order and being in the proper
manner that you can climb above that
let's say like Abel and that you can
make the proper sacrifices and that you
can set yourself right and you can set
your family right and you can set the
world right and that the mere
possibility that that might occur that
that might be within the realm of
potential means that you have a moral
obligation to exercise the
responsibility to take care of yourself
as if you're something that matters and
that if you did that properly it might
turn out that what you did would matter
that it would matter to you that it
would be meaningful in the way that
things that matter are meaningful and
that it would matter to everyone around
you
if you've explicitly formulated a set of
goals and you're pursuing them
then you've adopted the responsibility
to act in a certain manner to make those
goals realize themselves that's
that's responsibility that you've
adopted rather than
responsibility that's been imposed on
you assuming that you've thought through
the goals and you find your spirit in
harmony with those goals
um you can consult your resentment I
think that's a very useful step if you
find yourself angry and bitter about the
things that you are responsible for
doing then that's an indication that you
might be operating under some unhealthy
compulsion
that you're rebelling and that's the
reason for the resentment against the
insistence that you act in a certain way
although it's also possible that you're
just immature and that you're rebelling
against the discipline that's necessary
to attain the goals that you genuinely
do want to attain and that are valid and
that you are
what actively engaged in constructed
so you have to get that straight and
some of that's a consequence of thought
and again some of that's a consequence
of of discussion with other people
with whom you're
intimate enough to have a conversation
like that and perhaps they have
conversations about similar things with
you if you're fortunate
we should make much more of an effort to
ensure that kids are unbelievably
proficient readers and a lot of that is
going to involve early automatization of
letter and phoneme and syllable and word
recognition so because what happens is
when you teach a child to read first of
all you teach them the alphabet and the
sounds and we have an alphabetic
language thank God because it makes
things much simpler and so you teach
them the letters and then the two letter
combinations and then the three letter
combinations then they can sound out
syllables and then they get words but it
isn't until you can read phrases
automatically at a glance that you can
read for content and pleasure
and so a lot of kids get stuck
especially if they don't come from
particularly literate homes where where
all of this is sort of taught you know
maybe starting at
you know 12 months when they're first
dragging a book around and becoming
familiar with the book as an object
right before they even learn to read
you got to get kids through that
automatization phase and that requires
intense Mass practice and that's not
that intrinsically interesting right but
if you can get them to the point where
they can read for Content well then it
starts to become interesting just as
interesting let's say as going to a
movie or perhaps playing a video game
and so that has to be made an absolute
priority and and the far if the
faculties of Education were doing their
job they would have produced technology
to solve that problem for virtually
every child because it is only a matter
of practice smarter kids will learn
faster but with enough practice pretty
much everybody is going to get there
so and then there's the marketing issue
it's like well why should you read well
do you want to be stupid
you want to be stupid what happens when
you're stupid you walk into walls
because you don't see them and if
someone comes along who's more educated
than you more literate and canier
they'll just
you'll lose man you'll lose and you'll
lose too because you can't think
properly so you won't aim at the right
things and you won't be informed by the
great individuals of the past and you
need that we're historical creatures
this isn't optional
so part of it has to be
marketing for lack of a better word it's
not really that it's an explanation why
be literate
because it makes you
it helps you become who you could be
helps you move out into the world and
have your Great Adventure and to bring
people along God only knows what you can
do if you've got your words lined up
properly
and young men would listen to that if
someone who knew what they were talking
about was telling them that
as you found out
well if you want an answer to the first
question
which is how do I find the person who's
right for me you actually start by
asking the second question which is what
can I bring to the table for someone
else and if you're really good at
bringing something to the table for
someone else hey man people might be
lining up to be your partner and if
they're not then you might think well
maybe I'm just not bringing the right
thing to the table
and that's worth thinking especially if
you're desperate you're lost and you're
alone it's like hmm maybe I got this
wrong and I you know I usually sort of
top that with a suggestion that even if
you did find the person who was perfect
for you and they're that perfect what
makes you think they wouldn't take one
look at you and run screaming away and
they likely would if they were that
perfect because you know really are you
that much of a catch
and if you think you are you know that
might be part of the problem
um
so so look so that's one right intimate
relationship so I would say to you at
the crossroads develop a vision for your
relationship it's hard to say what the
soul means metaphysically because you
know say beyond the cons beyond the
confines of a single human being
we do have this sense that the soul can
expand itself into something that's
greater than well greater than it has
been it has this capacity for growth and
we do have the sense that the soul can
expand itself to the point where it it's
enlightened for lack of a better word
that it's working
as efficiently as possible to transform
everything that's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
about the world into what's positive and
good and and and that it does that as a
consequence of confronting the world
with courage and truth and I I think
that's right and I do think that that
means that the soul participates in
something Eternal which is the attempt
of being itself to transform what's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
into what's good and that human beings
actually do participate in that and that
that's part of the reason that our
ancient tradition insists that we're
made in the image of God
and I think that it's a mistake to
underestimate the importance of that
because I don't think that you can live
life a life of sufficient profundity to
protect yourself from being corrupted by
suffering malevolence without adopting a
responsibility that's commensurate with
that set of ideas I think that you
either Orient yourself upward
you know to the star above the Horizon
and try desperately to improve the
structure of being
or you work at counter purposes to it
and make things worse I don't think
there's a middle ground
in fact to the degree there is a middle
ground it tilts towards the negative
because people who try to occupy the
middle ground
generally try to accrue the benefit
let's say without adopting any of the
risk and that's not
acceptable not helpful
so
that's a soul to me if you're having a
discussion with someone
and they're talking about things that
don't have those characteristics right
that they haven't made personal then the
conversation is almost never interesting
it's because the person is it's just a
they're just they really are an empty
shell through which
ideology cliches and slogans are pouring
there's nothing about that that's
compelling because you don't see
the grappling you don't see that the
other person has grappled with the ideas
and come to their own unique conclusions
and it really is in that mingling of the
abstract and the particular that
compelling wisdom is to be found
concretely speaking well there's ways of
earning your knowledge and part of that
is reformulating it in your own words
that's thinking it through right and
discussing it until you have it at hand
you can talk about it and you can
generalize from it because you truly
understand it but a huge part of that is
also putting it into practice and
deriving your own conclusions as a
consequence and some of that can be done
with debate it's like here's an idea I
came across and
here's the idea and here's what I think
it means and this is
how I think it would change things if I
put it into practice this is how I
understand this idea and what do you
think of that like that's a good debate
or discussion you know because then the
other person can say well I don't really
agree with the way you formulated that
or I don't agree with your conclusions
and hopefully it's a real discussion and
not just one-upmanship you know because
that's a pretty dull game
well let's say you want to fix up your
house
which is actually quite a lot like
fixing yourself up which is a very
common dream metaphor yeah well the
first thing you want to do is go look
around and see what needs to be fixed
you know and and this the interesting
thing about that and this is akin to
what comedians do is that as soon as
you're willing to admit comedians look
at a problem and then rise above it
right away and make a joke about it but
as soon as you're willing to admit that
you have a problem
then you're you've immediately contacted
the part of yourself that's at least
strong enough to admit that you have a
problem and so soon the act of admitting
the problem is actually the first step
to solving it yes you might say well and
it's an optimistic step because you
might say oh my God I can't admit to I
that I have a problem because what if I
can't solve it well exactly so then
maybe you won't admit to it if you do
admit to it you're simultaneously
admitting to the possibility that you
could solve it yes and then it can
actually become something that's
optimistic you can say well my life is
horrible it's like okay but I'm doing 50
things wrong well great I can fix those
things and then maybe it wouldn't be so
horrible what's the best method to
retain what you read and to be able to
use it in conversation
oh well it's very difficult really to
retain anything without recalling it so
look if you encounter something
and then you encounter it again you can
usually recognize that you've
encountered it before that's recognition
memory so it's it's an important form of
memory it's it's it's the memory that's
associated with familiarity but it's not
the same as being able to use something
exactly it's a rather shallow form of
memory even though it's necessary
in order to be able to use something
you have to recall it this is also very
useful hint for studying like if you're
studying and you have to remember what
you want to do is study and then you
want to write down what you just learned
so you read a paragraph you close the
book and you write down what you
remember or you read a chapter and you
close the book and you write down what
you remembered or at least you sit there
and you try to remember because the way
you remember is by practicing
remembering
okay so if you're reading and you want
to use it in conversation
and you have to think about what you
read you have to put it in your own
words it's often helpful to close the
book and write it down or to associate
it with some problem that you're
currently trying to solve you have to
take the knowledge and make it your own
and then and then that alters the
structure through which you look at the
world and that changes the way that you
think so that when you have a
conversation the next time that you're
going to have the conversation in a
different way so merely reading isn't
enough you have you have to read and
think and recall and it's the act of
recalling that produces the remembering
and it's that act of remembering that
puts that material at hand for you I've
had clients many clients in their 30s
who are trying to this is more true with
women I would say a lot of women who are
very high achieving who establish their
career goals at 30 and then
want to differentiate differentiate out
their life they want to have a husband
they want to have a family they're
trying to figure out how to do that and
one of the things I've noticed that
around 30
you really have to stop comparing
yourself in some ways to other people
and the reason for that is that the
particularities of your life are so
idiosyncratic that there isn't anyone
really all that much like you you know
because the details of your life happen
to matter and so maybe you compare
yourself to some rock star or something
like that and you know the person's rich
and famous and glamorous and all that
but you know they're alcoholic and they
use too much cocaine and they've had
three divorces and it's like how the
hell do you
make sense out of that is that someone
that you should judge yourself harshly
against or not the answer is you don't
know because you don't know all the
details of their lives and who do you
know that you can compare yourself to
that's easy you
yesterday
so here's a good goal it's something
like well aim high and I really mean
that it's like and we'll talk about that
a little bit too aim high but use as
your control yourself it's like so your
goal is to make today some tiny
increment better than yesterday and you
can use better you can Define better
yourself this doesn't have to be some
imposition of external morality you know
you know where you're weak and
insufficient where you could improve
think okay well this is what I'm like
yesterday if I did this little thing
things would be just an increment better
and well that's a great thing because
you get the ball rolling and
incremental Improvement is Unstoppable
you can actually implement it and it
starts to generate Pareto distribution
like consequences it starts to compound
and I've seen that happen in people's
lives over and on people writing all the
time and tell me that they're doing that
but I've seen that happen in people's
lives continually they make a goal a
goal that the goal should be
how could I conceive of my life so that
if I had that life it would clearly be
worth living so I wouldn't have to be
bitter resentful deceitful arrogant and
vengeful
you act out the things that you would do
when you're normal even when you're
depressed you know you don't want to see
people well it doesn't matter you go see
them because it's better than not seeing
them you know and you find when you do
see them that it's better it'll go
better than you think but you can't
isolate yourself and you're anxious and
so you want to avoid you don't want to
go out you'd rather stay home and sit in
the chair and just sit there and like in
a frozen positions like you can't do
that you have to go out and go grocery
shopping and go out and have coffee and
all of those things it doesn't matter
whether you enjoy them it matters that
you do them because that's what you do
that's what you do in order to maintain
your health
if you're writing to figure out what you
think then you're going to use what you
think to guide your action and the
consequence of that is going to be how
your life turns out so I'm dead serious
about what I write because because I
know what the pathway is it's like you
don't you don't communicate in a false
manner because if you do you'll warp the
structure that guides your actions and
you will absolutely absolutely 100
percent suffer for that I mean one of
the things I've learned as a clinical
psychologist is that I've never seen
anyone it's really a terrifying thing
I've never seen anyone get away with
anything ever
it the chickens always come home to
roost so and sometimes it might you know
let's say you get away with something
it's like yeah you think so man you wait
five years from now seven years from now
it'll come back is that Karma
it's more like yes I think it's the same
idea but it's more like
you you can't you you don't have the
power to manipulate reality
like you have the power to bring about
reality in some sense because you
confront potential and through your
actions and and your communicative
intent you turn potential into reality
but you don't have the you don't have
the power to bend reality without it
snap you don't think so
you don't think so so you don't think
Visionaries and influencers have the
ability to bend reality no I don't think
they bend it I think that they they they
I mean you can bring new things into
being but you can't you can't get away
with a falsehood no you can definitely
bring new things into being you can't
get away with a false yes that's it
amazing okay makes sense and and you
can't get away with weak thinking either
because I mean any more than you can get
away with improper action it just
doesn't work
so you're you're contending it's it's
why I mean one of the themes in my
writing is the danger of falsehood and
at any at every level it's like well if
you tell the truth to the degree that
you can or at least don't lie that I
think that's rule eight
um then you have reality on your side
you got to decide and you want reality
on your side or do you want reality
against you
I wouldn't recommend the whole reality
against you thing because you're not
going to win you're going to get
flattened
and so I'm very careful with what I say
and I'm very careful with what I write
we are thrown
challenges and that they're that and
that in some sense those are best
construed as tests of our ethical
ability so what Jung thought his idea
was something like this that at the
beginning of time people were
unconscious and that Consciousness
emerged with all of its catastrophes
consciousness of death for example and
one way out of the burden of
Consciousness was to return to
unconsciousness you can do that with
alcohol you can do that by being
dependent you can do that by failing to
grow up you refuse the burden of
Consciousness by becoming unconscious
again but there's another way for it
which is to become even more conscious
so the idea would be a little bit of
Consciousness is like an illness but if
you can expand that Consciousness
upwards enough then it's some something
it starts to become something that it's
all that is its own cure and that partly
what your goal is while you suffer
through life is to heighten your
Consciousness to the point where
everything gets integrated enough so so
that that's proper medication for the
disease of self-consciousness
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong
that you could stop doing
right so it's it's a fairly it's a
fairly limited attempt first of all
we're not going to say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense but we will presume
that there are things that you're doing
that for one reason or another you know
are not in your best interests there's
something about them that you just know
you should stop they're kind of
self-evident to you other things you're
going to be doubtful about you're not
going to know which way is up and which
way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do now some
of those you won't stop doing for
whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or you don't believe it's
necessary or it's too much of a
sacrifice or you're angry or resentful
or or afraid who knows so forget about
those for now
but there's another subset that you
could stop doing it might be little
thing well that's fine stop doing it
and see what happens and what will
happen is your vision will clear a
little bit
and then something else will pop up in
your field of apprehension that you will
also know you should stop doing and that
you could stop doing because you
strengthened yourself a bit by stopping
doing the particular stupid thing that
you were doing before that just puts you
together a little bit more and you could
do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and and
you know that doesn't necessarily mean
that you're going to ever be able to
formulate a clear and final picture of
what constitutes the truth and the good
but it does mean that you'll be able to
continually move away from what's
untruth and what's bad
and you know that's not a bad start
how do you bear
the suffering that is at the Crux of
life
without becoming tempted and embittered
that's really really difficult now you
know someone might point out go ahead
and be bitter see where that gets you
and if you have any sense and generally
people have at least some they know that
being sick and bitter is worse than just
being sick and that being right it's
worse but it's very hard temptation to
avoid sometimes you want to be bitter
just out of spite in some sense because
things are so terrible all you've got
left is your willingness to shake your
fist you know and say well you know
really is this like this many poisonous
snakes really that's like maybe I could
have learned with just one or two not a
hundred
so but we're stuck we're all stuck with
that and I think we're stuck with it at
every level of our life in some senses
how do we maintain a
high order moral orientation in spite of
suffering and malevolence I first
started to understand that
what we perceive in some real sense
isn't exactly material reality and
partly that's because that's actually
impossible
and I mean that technically and that's
something we could go into in great
depth because that realization paralyzed
a number of fields it really started to
come to the Forefront many fields in
about in the early 1960s especially in
AI when the AI type started to try to
make machines that could see the world
in some sense like we do and then act in
the world and what they instantly
realized was that oh
there isn't just something there that we
see this is way harder than we ever
possibly imagined in fact it's so hard
that it looks like it might be
impossible in some sense so how the hell
do we do it and like we still don't have
robots that can move around the world
like we do you know endless Generations
I'm not I'm not maybe it's improved the
last time I looked at this great detail
we didn't have robots that could fold
laundry very efficiently either so yeah
well a lot of these so-called simple
things like seeing well it's half your
brain it takes you half your brain to
see and most animals like we see way
better than almost all animals say
really Eagles Raptors really because we
have bald eagles in my back yeah they
can see they they their eyes are the
same size as yours and they have two
foveal spots Eagles uh Falcons they're
the animals that can see better than us
but other than that
it's us
and it's half our brain just to see well
so why well you're a physicist you
understand that reality is composed of
levels of being right from the subatomic
up to the cosmic it's like well first of
all how do you specify the proper level
of analysis
well one of the things that's quite
interesting psychologically is that we
have short words
are generally used to describe things
that manifest themselves to us at our
level of analysis cat we see a cat we
don't see a species we don't see Cats
sub parts we see this cat well why well
that's that's the level that's most
biologically relevant to us given our
embodiment that's an evolutionary answer
and so we see what we see first of all
what we see a lot of is memory but we
see something that's overlaid on the
world we actually see the overlay and
hopefully it reflects what's underneath
and generally it does and it's a hell of
a shock to us when when we make a
perceptual error
but I see I and then I started to learn
especially from Reading Jeffrey gray
that we we also see the world within a
motivated frame
and he was influenced by Norbert weiner
who was one of the world's first
cybernetic scientists essentially a
great influence on AI yeah and and gray
never talked about narrative but the
frame that he described that we see and
in animals as well basically has a point
a and a point B so we're always moving
towards a goal if we're mobile animals
and I thought Oh Well the description of
the movement from point A to point B
that's the simplest unit of meaning
that's a story
and then I learned that a better story
is a story about how stories transform
and so those are actually perceptual
frames of reference that transform and
then I understood that
if you don't have respect for the
transformation process above all else
then you can't transform your perceptual
frames when necessary and then you can't
adapt to error and that destroys you and
so that's that's all part of that when
you organize your perceptions around a
goal
that provides a container for your
negative emotions so if I want to walk
across the stage because I think that
getting to the other side is preferable
to being here so that's a hierarchy of
value that place is better than this
place
than when I observe myself undertaking
the actions that will get me to that
place that's comforting and provides
security because it shows that the
structure that I'm using to organize my
perceptions and to reduce the world to
manageability
is sufficiently accurate so that I can
implement it
and so we seem to inhabit those
structures all the time whenever we're
looking at the world whenever we're
interacting we specify a goal and so
that's an ethical Enterprise and we
organize our emotions within the
specification of that goal and then we
produce hierarchies of goals so you know
you go to you
you sit down in front of your computer
so you can write a paper and you write a
paper so that you can finish an essay
and you finish an essay so that you can
get a grade in a class and get a grade
in class so that you can graduate with a
degree and you do that so that you can
get a job and you do that so that you
can be what a good husband a good wife a
good citizen and you do that so you can
be a good person
there's a hierarchy of ethic that
permeates the entire Enterprise right
from the microcosm up to the macrocosm
and I think that's something like the
whole landscape of religious value with
the
outermost container so be a good person
let's say that's the
ultimate aim of the religious Enterprise
that's something like the imitation of
Christ in the most fundamental sense and
all the things that you do within that
are a reflection of that or you're
confused and chaotic and if everyone's
doing that at the same time then you
have a society that's integrated and
aiming up and capable of telling the
truth something like that does that seem
reasonable
so what's the proposition here well I
think when we describe these Frameworks
of perception
the name we give to the description of a
framework of perception is a story
and I think the reason that we like
stories so much is because we need
to establish Frameworks of perception in
order to operate in the world and to
allow ourselves to
be integrated peacefully with other
people
and so we're extraordinarily interested
in anything that has a narrative basis
and the reason we're interested in that
is because we're trying to build within
ourselves and collectively the structure
that enables us to perceive the world
without undue confusion and chaos and in
a manner that provides some value to us
and some sustainability that's the goal
overall
and
that seems to me to be the goal of the
entire religious Enterprise and so
is it possible that
well I guess that's as that's the claim
I thought I'd
elaborate out a little bit today is that
the Bible is true
in a very strange way
it's true in that
it provides the basis for
truth itself
and so it's like a meta truth right
without it there without it there
couldn't even be the possibility of
Truth
and so maybe that's the most true thing
the most true thing isn't some truth per
se it's that which provides the
precondition for all judgments of Truth
and it seems to me that
I can't see any holes in that argument
and I can't see any holes in it from a
scientific perspective either because I
think we do know well enough now as
scientists that the problem of deriving
ethical direction from the collection of
facts is an intractable problem there's
too many facts there's an infinite
number of facts they do not provide an
unerring guide for Action they can't
there's too many of them they have to be
prioritized
and as soon as they are prioritized well
then you're in the ethical domain and
then that begs the question what's the
valid ethical domain and the postmodern
answer is well there isn't one it's all
the expression of domination and power
and I think that's nonsense I I don't
think that's a tenable solution I think
that
we stumbled onto the proper answer in
some sense in our religious Enterprise
which is that we aim at what's highest
or or we don't
we aim at what's highest jointly or
we're divided we aim at what's highest
and that's gives meaning to all the
things we do that are subordinate parts
of that we aim at what's highest and
that's what collects us and gives us
structure all of that you know singly
and jointly
and that's all what we've been trying to
communicate
all these centuries as we've been trying
to communicate the whole religious
Corpus generation after generation and
to sort this out and to straighten it
out and to try to understand it
and uh
I think that's where we're at now
if you're looking for certainty
the reality of suffering is certain
I mean
what do you accept as evidence Above All
Else
that's a good question that's a hard
question but I would say pain is up
there
it's very difficult not to believe in
the reality of your own pain
it's somewhat easier not to believe in
the reality of other people's pain
that's not so easy either you know but
it's your pain seems to be
undeniably real
and so
it does beg a question which is you know
if pain is undeniably real is that which
overcomes pain even more real
and I think that's in some sense that's
the idea that lyrics behind the idea of
the Resurrection when you see people who
are Noble in spite of their suffering it
is ennobling it is uplifting right like
really it is and
um and it's been striking to me too
people want to be encouraged in that
direction I mean part of the reason that
my lectures I would say have been
successful to the degree that they have
been is because people find them
encouraging and that actually seems to
work like it seems to be positive
because it is good news well it seems to
me I mean it isn't necessarily the case
that that would be the case you know
because it could have been that I would
have said encouraging things to people
there's more to you than meets the eye
and you're capable of more than you're
demanding of yourself and you know if
you took on your responsibility and face
the things that you're trying to avoid
that your life would be richer and
better and for you and for everyone
around you and the result of that could
have been that thousands of people would
come to me and say you know I gave that
a pretty good shot and it your advice is
really awful and everything is well
seriously like I took on that
responsibility it just bloody crushed me
and I'm way worse off than I was before
and everything's gone to hell around me
and like thanks a lot buddy and that and
that it's not like that's a completely
incomprehensible possibility but that
doesn't seem to be what happens is what
generally happens is that young people
in particular but not only come to me
and say look I've been trying to take on
more responsibility and to face the
things I've been avoiding and everything
is way better it's like okay well isn't
that something to be onto something well
then you ask yourself well what's the
limit of that because that's the
religious question fundamentally is well
if you took on all the responsibility
you couldn't take on
and you faced everything that you needed
to face
what would you be like who would you be
and how would the world transform around
you and well if if the partial answer is
well if I do that a little bit things
get a fair bit better then the next
question might be well
what if you did that completely
and I don't think that's possible in
some sense right it's like you know
Perfection is a horizon that always
recedes but it isn't obvious to me what
the upper limit of that is and certainly
we do see people I mean Saints
it's a Francis of assessment you kind of
pushed the limit and the miraculous
things happen around them and maybe in
the literal sense and if not in the
literal sense close enough you know for
all intents and purposes and so that's
heartening I mean I
tear myself apart about this in many
ways because I think
perhaps it's possible to take on too
much responsibility and to crush
yourself as a consequence maybe that's a
sin of Pride who knows it's certainly
possible but my experience so far has
been that
when you see people bear their suffering
nobly
there's nothing in that but good
not something and then when you see
people take on more responsibility and
decide that they're going to aim up and
and
confront their suffering honestly and
forthrightly that their lives get better
and the lives of people around them get
better too
and so it's that's very strange as well
because it also means that the pathway
to less suffering
is through suffering
right and that's kind of that would be
hopeful if the world was constituted
that way it's like well there's
suffering how do you make it worse run
away
how do you make it better confront it
yeah but it's suffering it's like yeah
but it's there there it is it's right
there it's a precondition for existence
or something like that and it's like you
have something important to do as well
and you confront it and that's the
pathway to transcending it
I was watching this movie King Arthur by
Guy Ritchie and when when the new king
young King Arthur takes his sword he has
flashbacks to his evil Uncle killing his
father and it just it's so terrible that
he can't hold on to the sword
and I thought well what's Richie doing
there it's well that's the case for all
of us isn't it because when we look into
the past and we see our evil uncles it's
just a complete bloody catastrophic Mass
isn't it slavery and genocide and War
and oppression and like and that's on
all of us isn't it and it's always
lurking there in the background and so
is that male power well yes in some ways
I mean if you don't give a man a sword
he can't use a sword right so not giving
him a sword is one way of making sure
he's peaceful but it's not the it's not
the optimal way and besides if you
men they become far more
dangerous
they've become dangerous in an UNT
terrible underground fashion of course
the same is exactly true a few
women but we're speaking particularly of
boys because I suppose there's an
education crisis among boys and young
men
well you want to encourage that power
because it's actually a tremendous Force
for good if it's brought under control
and so but that's a hard thing to get
right and it also requires a lot of
trust and work on the part of women
because they want to it's like Beauty
and the Beast right because beauty
entices that Beast who's a real who's
real but uncivilized and dangerous she
sort of entices him into becoming
fully developed and that's what a woman
has to do when she you know has that
work project that she marries or has a
long-term relationship with
but
it's much better to encourage with with
faith and trust
it's a mistake to be fatally cynical
about politics because for all the
reasons there are to be fatally cynical
about politics there's much more reason
to be fatally cynical about the conflict
that will inevitably arise or the
Tyranny that will inevitably manifest
itself if we can't handle the dirty
business of politics properly
so I would say don't become prematurely
cynical about it the next thing I would
say is
what do you know
and that's a very important question
it's like
what does it mean to get into politics
exactly
does that mean to seek political power
does that mean to seek power
well first of all you shouldn't be
seeking power you should be seeking
competence
and in order to seek competence you
better know something and so I would say
well if you want to get into politics
you want to educate yourself you know in
all the things you need to be educated
in life I mean you can you can start to
play the political game to familiarize
yourself with it but you know it's not
such a bad idea to well it's not such a
bad idea to have a job for a while and
and maybe a career and maybe it's not
such a bad idea to have a successful
career upon in which people are
dependent on you so that you start to
understand what that sort of
responsibility means and then maybe it's
not such a bad idea to have a family
because like human beings mature adult
human beings tend to have families and
and they transform when they have
families because when you have children
then someone becomes more important to
you than you are and you're not mature
until that happens and so that's
necessary and so I would say well make
sure that if you're looking to get into
politics that you're even more looking
to get into competence and that you
learn everything you can possibly learn
that would make you a reasonably wise
person by the time you attain whatever
level of power you might Authority let's
say you might be seeking I mean I've
seen lots of people get into politics
you know this happens with ideologues
and the way they ratchet themselves up
the power hierarchy is by being more
effective avatars puppets of their
particular ideological stance and
there's nothing about that that's useful
there's nothing in it that will solve
any real world problems and there's
plenty that will make it much worse and
so if that's what getting into politics
means I would say stay the hell away
from it but if it's a matter of
developing your character and then at
some point adopting your social
responsibility then go for it and more
power to you because we need people who
are competent and careful and truthful
and courageous and forthright to enter
the political sphere so that things
don't degenerate and hopefully have some
ounce of at least maintaining themselves
or improving
so
there's you need what do you need to
know you you need to be really good at
at least one thing you have to
specialize you have to be a great
networker you have to know a lot of
people you have to be honest you have to
be articulate you have to you have to
have a vision you have to have a
strategy you have to know something
about history and economics and politics
be good to know something about science
you know you have to be a polymath of
sorts before you should dare to enter
that realm with any degree of confidence
because otherwise all you are is a Loose
Cannon and you'll come up with global
proposals to improve improve the world
you know by waving your wand that will
do nothing but make everything worse I
speak to my audience this seriously and
pessimistically in some sense about
part of the substructure of existence
the the Mortal side The Fragile side but
conclude I would say that
there's more to you than there is
to what faces you
and I believe that to be true and and
then I'm encouraging people to to
attempt that and then I think part of
the reason that the book has been
perhaps particularly popular among men
is because I don't think we do a very
good job at the moment of encouraging
men we have this idea that there's
something intrinsically oppressive about
the patriarchy and about masculinity in
general and I think that's nonsense I
think that
strong honest truthful courageous
men pursuing noble goals is of great
benefit to everyone male and female
alike
resentment is a key human motivation and
I would say it's I'm it's a great
teacher to to listen to your resentment
is one of the best things you can
possibly do you have to admit that it
exists first and then you have to admit
to the fantasies that it's generating
and you have to admit to what you would
regard as the way out of it so that's
all very difficult because it means
learning things about yourself that you
probably don't want to learn but
resentment only means one of two things
it means either like shut the hell up
grow up quit whining and get on with it
that's one thing it means or someone is
playing the Tyrant to you might even be
you and you have something to say and do
that you should say and do to put it to
a stop and so maybe and resentment can
show you the pathway to doing that
um
there's a meditation on resentment and
one of the one of the principles that I
extracted from that is like a resentful
person wants other people to change
and if you're resentful then your
motivations aren't trustworthy in fact
they're very very dark and that's why I
went to the extreme with people like
panzram and the Columbine killers
um
resentful people who want to change the
world are not to be trusted
what should you do instead how do you
treat your own resentment I would say
well there's a there's a great I read
this great line in the T.S Eliot play
called the cocktail party and in it this
woman comes up to a psychiatrist I think
this is in this chapter and she says
you know I'm having a really rough time
of it I'm suffering badly my life is not
going well and and then she says uh I
hope that there's something wrong with
me
and the psychiatrist says what the hell
do you mean by that and she says well
here's how I look at it there's either
something wrong with the world and I'm
just in it and that's how it is and then
like what am I going to do about that
because it's the whole world or maybe I
could be fortunate and there's something
wrong with me that's causing all this
unnecessary suffering and if I would I
could just set it right I could learn
and I could set it right
and so
well I've been thinking about that for a
very long time and I think well if your
life isn't going the way it is you know
you can find someone else to blame which
is pretty convenient for you and also
relatively easy or you could think okay
I don't like life I don't like the way
my life is unfolding
um maybe I don't like life in general
because it's tragic and and tainted with
evil how do I know if my judgment is
accurate
and the question is well have I really
done everything I possibly could to set
my life straight
because maybe I shouldn't be judging it
it's quality or the quality of life
itself or being itself for that matter
if I haven't done everything I possibly
could to set my life straight
well so there's a there's task solution
who I'm a great I'm a great admirer of
social Nets and his book the gulag
archipelago was one of the things that
brought down the Soviet Union and he
said that one man who stopped lying
could bring down a tyranny and you know
he said that with some Authority I think
you could easily make the case that the
gulag archipelago is the greatest
book of the 20th century I mean there's
other contenders obviously but he said
when he was in the gulag camps you know
meditating on how the hell he got there
and he had a rough life man I mean first
of all he was on the Russian front at
the beginning of World War II and then
he was thrown in the gulag camps and
that was just the beginning of his
adventures man he had a rough life he
was in the camps he was thinking what
the hell like how that what how did I
get here what's going on and he had
Hitler and Stalin to blame right so if
you have if you need someone to blame
man Hitler and stellen that that's great
but he he that isn't what he did he said
he meditated for a while once he
realized that he might have something to
do with in some strange way with the way
things turned out for him and he said he
went over his life with a fine-tooth
comb in his memory he thought okay
where did I go wrong but by my own
judgment when when I when there was a
path in front of me when did I take the
path that I knew I shouldn't take
because you all know that right you know
sometimes you don't know if what you're
doing is good or if it's bad
it's just ignorance you just don't know
but sometimes you bloody well know and
you do the thing you know you shouldn't
do anyways that happens a lot and why do
you do that spike is part of it
stupidity there's all sorts of reasons
but you certainly know you do it
solzhenitzen thought okay well what
would happen if I took responsibility
for where I am in this concentration
camp and then I went over my whole life
and tried to figure out all the things I
did that were wrong by my own estimation
that increased the probability that I
would get here and then what would
happen if I tried to set them all right
now in the present and that's why he
wrote the gulag archipelago and one of
the consequences of that as I said was
It sped the dissolution of the Soviet
Empire so hey that's not bad eh like you
make a real confession you really repent
you you do your Penance which is writing
this book and you completely change the
geopolitical landscape of the world it's
like and that that's worth thinking
about because it's not only
soldiernitzen who did that Nelson
Mandela did something quite similar it's
not so impossible and so the idea that
what you should do if you're feeling
resentful about the nature of being or
suffering too much for your own life
let's say is straighten the damn thing
out like seriously try it for a year
even try it for a week try not doing the
things you know you shouldn't do try not
saying the things you know to be false
and just watch what happens you might as
well give it a shot right it's not all
that happens though when they eat the
fruit of the tree of the knowledge of
Good and Evil because it's not called
the fruit of the tree of the North
knowledge of nakedness it's called the
fruit of the tree of the knowledge of
Good and Evil and I thought about that
for a tremendous amount of time it's
like what in the world because I assume
these old stories make sense you know
it's a game I play it's like they're old
they've been around a long time I'm not
sure why they're there but there they
are they're at the basis of our culture
like many many of the stories that we
depend on depend on them our whole
culture grew out of their Roots let's
say and so I assume that our ancestors
who managed to survive conditions that
would have done a lot of us in very
rapidly I can tell you were a lot
smarter than we think and that the
mysterious processes that that produce
these stories and compelled us to
remember them are a lot more
psychologically significant than we
generally tend to presume so I give them
the benefit of the doubt and try to
understand why it is that they might
make sense instead of assuming that they
don't and that that's not easy
as they're complicated stories and so I
thought about this nakedness knowledge
of Good and Evil idea for a very very
long time like about 20 years puzzling
it out what the hell is the relationship
between discovering that you're naked
and discovering good and evil and then
one day mostly because of studying
totalitarianism
totalitarianism and the atrocity the
proclivity for people to commit atrocity
in the service of their group belief or
maybe just because that's what they were
like
clued me in and I thought I see this is
one of the things that really makes
people different than animals it's like
you know it's one thing to realize that
you're naked to realize that you're
naked means that you know that you're
limited in time and space that you're
mortal and that you're you're subject to
degeneration and to social humiliation
and to your own harsh judgment all of
that nakedness to Know That You're
vulnerable against the world and
definitely a source of shame because of
that
um and and a felt lack of
self-sufficiency and no wonder and no
wonder it's understandable but the other
thing is is that this is and this is the
rub it's like
if you're out in the belt and you're not
being very careful and a hungry lion
jumps on you and eats you you don't
really think of the lion as evil I mean
you might write at that moment but you
know philosophically it's not evil it's
just hungry and as soon as it's not
hungry then
it goes and has a sleep and it's not up
to some malevolent trick it's it's done
for the day but human being that's a
whole different sort of creature and
because human being is capable of doing
terrible things to someone else and
consciously so you think well what's the
connection between that and nakedness
itself and it seems to be this is like
here's the thing is that once I realized
that I can be hurt you know I have a
self-conscious model of my own
vulnerability
then I can generalize that to other
people I can think oh this is
interesting here's how I can be heard by
myself here's how I can be hurt by
Society here's how I can be hurt by
nature and by the unknown and what that
implies is that well you can be hurt
with exactly the same mechanisms
and that immediately becomes part of my
what would you say my repertoire of
ability
and then all of a sudden you the world
is no longer
a walled
a Walled Garden and a well-watered place
but it's a moral story because with that
ability to inflict suffering comes the
knowledge of good and evil as far as I'm
concerned those are identical
propositions because now we have the
choice a deep choice about how we're
going to treat ourselves and each other
we can inflict tremendous pain and
suffering on each other in a very
voluntary and and conscious manner in in
a way that no other animal can manage
and that's the dawning of the moral
sense that capacity we now have to
choose to
mitigate or exaggerate suffering and and
that's not all but it's a huge part of
it how do we as human beings
think about reputation and does
reputation even matter anymore if anyone
can try to tear your reputation down
should we be focused on having a good
reputation yes
but you should you should you should be
more focused on deserving a good
reputation what does that mean don't
don't do things you know to be wrong
and even if you don't lie yep don't lie
don't be careless
see I'm fortunate I I suppose
I put all my lectures online
so virtually everything I've ever said
to a student is I mean obviously not but
a non-biased sample of everything that
I've ever said to students is available
well it hasn't come back to bite me
right and that's hundreds of hours
why well because I've been fortunate
enough not to have said anything
um fatal
maybe that's because I'm careful with my
words when you were possessed by those
ideas you might have been at least
partially authentic because one of the
things you might ask yourself is well
were they Stepping Stones to a better
you you know people get possessed all
the time because they admire certain
ideas and sometimes that admiration
impels them into a kind of
apprenticeship and so they were stupider
before they got possessed by that idea
and as they transformed themselves
across the apprenticeship cycle say
being apprenticed to this fad like idea
they learned something from it so you
know you might you might have learned
and grown as a consequence of what
possessed you now you know it's possible
that a lot of that spoke
to the development of parts of you that
you don't want to develop you know that
they spoke to your malevolence that
spoke to your desire to manipulate and
all of that and you have to sort that
out but
look I also don't think it's all that
easy to
figure out when you're authentic that
that's subtle you know you you your felt
sense of confidence in your words when
you're not trying to win is something
like your ability to judge your
authenticity you know are you saying
this to achieve a local land or are you
saying this because you have thought
deeply and this is the best expression
you can manage of a deeply held
conviction that's a lifetime it's a
lifetime of work or it's a lifetime work
to sort those things out the best I
could come up with was in my first book
well the first of the more popular books
in 12 rules for life
don't lie
now not lying is not the same as being
authentic exactly because
as your question highlights it's not
that easy to tell when you're telling
the truth right because well what the
hell do you know it's certainly not the
truth what you know it might be your
best approximation but it's certainly
not the truth and you're by no means
unerring in your ability to discern when
it is that you're even speaking your
truth because that's so complicated you
just have to practice doing that
continually to get anywhere near good at
it like so it's years and years of
effort to
of stringent moral effort to begin to
manage that but I do believe that people
can tell by and large when they're
outright lying and they can stop doing
that they can stop saying things they
know to be false
and so that's
the most obvious impediment to
authenticity is outright lies of
commission stop engaging in those stop
saying things you know to be false now
that begs the questions how do you know
them to be false well
that's complicated sometimes that's a
feeling of repugnance at your own words
sometimes it's a feeling of touchy
embarrassment so that if people call you
in what you say you get
disproportionately angry
um sometimes it's knowing a set of facts
that you haven't let affect the way you
think or present yourself you know
you're purposefully keeping yourself in
the fog as per rule three of Beyond
order
um those are all things you have to sort
out for yourself but I think it starts
with
an Act of Faith
and which is at least in part why
religious systems insist upon faith and
Faith isn't belief in something that no
one's saying would believe you know
that's that's a misapprehension of faith
faith is something like
a decision that
truth serves the good and the good is
worth serving and so therefore truth is
worth serving it's just that's an
axiomatic proposition
and you can debate its empirical
justification and of course we wouldn't
be tempted into temptation if we
couldn't debate it's empirical
justification because the objection is
yeah and what exactly does truth buy you
that falsehood wouldn't buy you better
and if you don't think that you're
tempted by that counter position well
then you don't know anything about
Temptation because that is the
temptation of the counterposition so and
it's powerful Temptation that's why it's
a statement of faith that just that that
um conquers it
it's a decision
so
you probably were possessed by an idea
but maybe there was something in you
that was striving to be authentic and
maybe you can speed that process of
transformation Along by vowing by taking
a vow and that's adopting a religious
commitment which is I'm going to serve
truth in the good despite the proximal
cost
and that's a statement of faith because
you're staking your life on that
right because every decision you make
from here on in will be a will be
affected by that by that decision so
it's a fundamental decision
and
hopefully that will guide you
in your Endeavor so that your possession
by cultural fads which might be a
necessary part of your apprenticeship
will be temporary and serve this
zigzagging path to something that's
better for you in the future
we don't understand Consciousness we
don't really understand its place in the
cosmos let's say but I'm not qualified
to answer such questions and I would say
though that no no one stops listening to
a symphony because they know it's going
to end
and so I think in some sense our proper
task is to find the meaning within the
finite when I have clinical clients who
were consumed with such questions
because you know you can pick a time
frame of evaluation that makes all your
efforts futile right well the sun isn't
going to envelop the earth I I think
it's four billion years so like get
ready it's like well what's the point of
stopping this baby from crying when the
sun is going to envelop the Earth and
form well yeah you all laugh right but
but that laughter you see that's a sign
of wisdom
you know that's preposterous why
I mean that's the existential question
right it's like well if all if we're all
doomed to ashes and Decay why do
anything well I used the baby crying for
a reason
I mean who in the world is going to use
that argument to not feed their baby
well why feed that thing in four million
years the sun's going to develop the
Earth it's like wrong time frame folks
and so what I would say and I did say to
my clinical clients if if you're
adopting a time frame that makes what
you're doing a pure trivial
the problem isn't necessarily what
you're doing although it might be and
you have to ask yourself that question
because perhaps you are engaging in
something that's more trivial than you
should be the problem is that your mind
which is capable of Leaping across
evaluative Frameworks has picked a time
frame inappropriate for the task so quit
doing that instead you could say well
why don't you practice adopting the time
frame that imbues your properly oriented
action with the deepest possible
apprehended meaning and why would you
not think that the fact that that
meaning manifests itself with the proper
choice of time frame why wouldn't you
accept the fact that's indication of a
valid Choice it certainly feels like it
you know what you know what it's like
you get engaged in something a deep
conversation a piece of music a piece of
art something you love doing someone you
love being with you get engaged in that
you lose your sense of temporality and
you don't pop out of it and think oh my
God I wish I would use the time frame
that made everything irrelevant because
of my you know cognitive Brilliance you
think hey we could do that some more
like how about all the time
and that's that's a good goal it's like
yeah how about that all the time and
then you've got time right when you're
engaged like that and I would say that's
a profound neurophysiological signal
that you're in the right place at the
right time right because it's
accompanied by a sense of deep
well-being and that's literally an
antidote suffering I I mean that
literally it's with many of my clients
who were suffering
what we would strive to do was not so
much make them happy because sometimes
that was impossible they were so
crippled in in so many ways often
physically and in pain
but something meaningful
I would keep them going
and keep them from straying and keep
them from thinking
homicidal and genocidal thoughts all of
that that meaning that's the antidote to
suffering and the question is well how's
that best to be found well that's an
empirical question you have to you have
to look in your own life and see where
meaning glimmers and then pursue that
right
that's what Harry Potter is doing by the
way when he's chasing the snitch just
thought I'd let you know and you know
you win the game if you catch that thing
well that's not exactly right you get
100 points but you know it'll do well of
course you're going to be disenchanted
because you were young and naive and so
being disenchanted is part of maturing
but the next part of maturing is to move
forward optimistically as an axiom of
your faith in mankind and yourself as an
recognition of your moral obligation to
do so
right so now your eyes are open you see
well you know there's a snake in the
garden
and Cain is your brother
foreign
well yeah it's always been that way
welcome to reality
so what do you do you allow that to make
you corrupt and nihilistic
not if you think that it's the
corruption and the nihilism that's the
problem
so you're obligated to be optimistic in
some sense
despite the evidence
and that's Faith so you know pick up
your cross and stumble uphill
consciously
and you bring back optimism in human
relations by structuring your own to the
best of your possible ability
and that'll expand outward as you become
more competent move through your life be
productive
generous kind Discerning wise educated
you be a good father
to everyone not the tyrant
that resentment breeds in your own heart
and that's an act of moral courage
and that's real maturity
so and and if you want an adventure well
there's one for you habit the
development maintenance of good
practices
habits
if you find yourself dissolute uh
neurotic if your tenants if your thought
tends in the nihilistic direction and
you tend to fall apart
organizing your
life across multiple Dimensions is a
good antidote it's not exactly thinking
do you have an intimate relationship if
not well probably you could use one
do you have contact with close family
members siblings or children or parents
or or people who are even more distantly
related if not you probably need that
do you see your friends a couple of
times a week and do something social
with them
do you have a way of
productively using your time outside of
employment are you employed do you have
a good job or at least a job that is
practically sufficient and that enables
you to
work with people who you like working
with even if the job itself is you know
mundane or repetitive or difficult
sometimes the relationships that you
establish
with in in an employment situation like
that can make the job worthwhile
um have you regulated your
response to Temptations pornography
alcohol abuse drug abuse is that under
control
um I would say
differentiate the problem
there's multiple
dimensions of attainment
ambition
pleasure responsibility all of that that
make up a life and
to the degree that it's possible you
want to optimize your functioning
on as many of those Dimensions as
possible you might also organize your
schedule
to the degree that you have that
capacity for discipline
do you get enough sleep
do you go to bed at a regular time do
you get up at a regular time
do you eat regularly and appropriately
and enough and not too much
are your days and your weeks and your
months characterized by some tolerable
repeatable structure
that that helps you meet your
responsibilities but also Shields you
from uncertainty and chaos and provides
you with
multiple sources of reward
those are all the questions that I would
decompose the problem into
the best way to avoid falling back into
nihilistic behaviors and thinking
people have like three well they have
four fundamental fears one is fear of
their own inadequacy and malevolence
that's that's a big fear man that can
really that can really do you in if you
confront it
accidentally and fully happens to
soldiers sometimes in battle when they
find themselves doing things they can't
believe they do and then we're afraid of
society that would be the oppressive
patriarchy because Society judges us
harshly and and mercilessly in many ways
and we don't like to plummet in the
what would you call it
we don't like to see our reputation
Savaged in front of the groups that we
identify with it's extraordinarily hard
on us emotionally for that to happen
which I wrote about for example in rule
one which is a a chapter at least in
part the details out the fact that the
neurochemical systems that track your
comparative status incompetence
hierarchies also regulate the balance
between your positive and negative
emotion such that if you suffer a social
defeat your proclivity to experience
negative emotion radically increases and
your proclivity to experience positive
emotion radically decreases and people
seriously do not like that and it's no
wonder because who wants to be
completely overwhelmed with sadness and
bitterness and anxiety and resentment
and disappointment and frustration and
grief and then also devoid of happiness
you know it's a very definition of hell
and if a status defeat will increase
that probability then we will fight very
hard to maintain our status positions
which we certainly do that's another
fear and then of course we have the fear
of Nature and we should because of
course nature despite being the
environment and this thing that we
should be striving to protect and
maintain is also trying with all of its
might constantly to make us ill and old
and kill us and is generally very
successful at all three and so there's
every reason to be afraid of Nature and
um
you know one night alone in the bush
will pretty much
convince you of that and then people are
also afraid of the unknown and so those
are the big categories of Terror that
human beings face and to be naked on
stage is to face at least two or three
of those
simultaneously you're probably not
particularly well suited for jobs that
require a tremendous amount of
transformation of thinking or a
tremendous amount of abstraction but
that doesn't mean there are no jobs for
you so jobs that are more stable and
repetitive
routine let's say you're better suited
for
vocational
jobs and there's vocational jobs
playing a
remarkably important role in our culture
so and hard work get you a long ways
and so you know I don't know what you
mean when you say low intelligence
you know I mean there are
catastrophically low intelligence
ratings say 60 and below
it's tough to find anything that you're
going to be able to be productive
in doing
and I don't know what to do about that
above that hard work is going to make a
huge difference
and aiming right so
aim at the vocation land of the
distribution
and put a plan in place
and stick to it and work diligently at
it that's what you've got you've got
your ability to work
and maybe you can capitalize on your
other personality attributes as well and
as I said already in this podcast you
can do a personality test and understand
myself.com I would also say on myself
authoring.com website There's an
opportunity for you to map out a plan
and this one of the to map out a plan to
write about your past but also to write
about your present self so the present
authoring program enables you to
do an inventory of your personality
strengths and weaknesses and
there's a virtues analysis and a false
analysis and I would say if you're leery
about your future for whatever reason
you should do the virtues analysis it's
like what have you got to offer
and hopefully you have the ability to
work hard and maybe you have other
personality attributes that are
important and that you could understand
and then capitalize on so I would say do
they understand myself.com personality
test do the virtues section of the
present authoring exercise at
self-authoring.com put together a plan
and aim at the vocation land of the job
distribution don't despair there's
plenty of opportunity at that level for
someone who's honest which is a huge
Advantage who has Integrity who's
willing to work hard
I'm not going to sugarcoat it you know
life is harder at the shallow end of the
gene pool let's say to use scars phrase
from The Lion King we're all at the
shallow end of the gene pool in some
regard you know
so
the cognitive end is that's a rough hit
but General cognitive ability isn't
everything even though it's a lot of
things
and so
aim Integrity hard work
a plan
that's what you've got
and so you have to make the best of it
I continually ask my
frequently let's say or yearly ask my
personality class attendees
if they heard the voice of conscience if
they had a feeling an emotion emotional
state let's say or a voice that informed
them when they had done something
ethically wrong and that perhaps made
them guilty as a consequence and
it was essentially a universal
experience and that's the voice of
society within I suppose that's one way
of thinking about it the freudians would
think about that as the voice of the
superego Jung Carl Jung would take that
conceptualization somewhat farther he
would have considered it the voice of
the self which is in part
the voice of the ethic that's derived
from the broader Community insofar as
that ethic is valid let's say but also
in part
the voice of the
more
thoroughly developed self that's still
striving to be born one thing you could
say is that
you you experience violations of your
conscience when
you're not acting like the better person
that you could possibly become
and so to some degree that's your higher
self operating you for failure to
develop in the appropriate Direction
and that seems to me to be
a reasonable way of conceptualizing it
now the one question might be how
error-prone is your conscience given
that you're not omniscient and
all right have an endless fascination
with the movie Pinocchio uh and part of
that is because it taught me something
very sophisticated about conscience in
that movie
Jiminy Cricket is given Divine
attributes he has the same initials as
Jesus Christ for example and
um
he is deemed
the voice of conscience Itself by by the
magical properties of of Mother Nature
essentially but in the movie it's
necessary for the puppet who's still
wooden-headed and still a marionette
whose strings are being pulled by others
it's necessary for the puppet to engage
in a dialogue with his conscience
because both of them have to inform the
other
and that seems to me approximately right
because I certainly saw people in my
clinical practice and know people in my
private life who seem to labor under a
two authoritarian
labor under the dictates of a two
authoritarian
conscience
maybe that's the internalized voice of a
relatively tyrannical father for example
uh
or you know exaggerated sensitivity to
the moral pressure exerted by the
broader social world
you have to
attend to your
guilt and yourself disgusting your
self-contempt and your
self-consciousness you have to
understand that the manifestation of
those emotions might well indicate a
moral failing on your part or a
uh
uh a lack that needs to be addressed
while at the same time considering that
it is not a straightforward matter to
deal fairly with yourself and
you can be too tormented by your
conscience too rigid too responsible
take on too much weight onto yourself
deny yourself in a manner that isn't
sustainable
and so forth that that a moral code a
moral way of being can become too rigid
and
and inflexible and despite its putative
aim upward
be something counterproductive I think
most of
the way out of that if there is one is
well careful thinking
you have to see what your conscience
says you have to see how you respond you
have to capture
that voice and your responses and and
you have to think it through but most of
that is done in dialogue with other
people rather than as the consequence of
internal thought
you know if you have a dispute with your
wife or your husband your intimate
partner sibling your parents anybody
close to you
and it's useful to for each of you in
the dispute too
ask yourself and the other person very
seriously
if you're at fault
or if they're at fault and and for both
of you to be able to contemplate
that you might be at fault and so might
the other person and then it's in your
best interest to sort out exactly
who's made the error and where and maybe
it's both of you and maybe at different
levels of analysis
um I think the same might be said about
your reaction to your conscience
it's not uncommon for me to talk to my
wife my kids my parents
my friends for that matter
about something I might be feeling maybe
I'm guilty about something I'm
self-conscious about something I'm angry
about something
um I feel impelled by my conscience to
do something as a consequence
to change something
uh
it's very helpful to discuss such things
with other people to say look here's
what I think I did wrong and here's how
I'm punishing myself but I'm not sure
that I'm not doing it in an exaggerated
way and
you gather other people's opinions and
listen to them carefully and
friends are extraordinarily useful in
that regard
and that can help you calibrate it
so I think most of what we do to decide
if our inner voice is healthy is discuss
it with other people and I believe as I
pointed out in my last book
explicitly that tremendous amount of our
sanity is maintained as a consequence of
social interaction
so
you can't find your authentic self
merely as a consequence of a journey
within I would say you you you're not
there's just not enough of you you have
to be informed by the broader social
world it's one thing to live properly
and that's not a trivial thing but it's
another thing to be able to articulate
yourself and to be able to negotiate and
generally speaking there's nothing about
that that isn't advantageous and even
introverted and anxious people can learn
to do that you know it's those are
learnable skills it's not easy but but
but you can manage it you can also speak
carefully you know and listen to what
you're saying and only try to say things
that you think are true that's also
unbelievably useful you have to feel
that out like is this really what I
believe or am I putting it Forward well
because I want to look good or I want to
dominate or I want to express
obliquely an emotion that I'm too
cowardly to come out and confront
directly or am I being manipulative
there's lots of reason that people use
language but what you really should use
it for is to State what you believe to
be true and then to let the consequences
of that unfold
and so that can also help you
simple truths
bluntly stated can be very powerful you
don't need a lot of verbal fluency under
those circumstances if there's evidence
of strength of character behind it look
it's good for you to go take your place
in the world have some ambition have
some have a vision have a goal have a
strategy try to try to be a good person
and not not because it's your duty
precisely because that's the proper way
to live we're in danger of undermining
all of that and it's not good for people
one of the things that I've really
learned for example recently is that
there's a or learn to articulate better
is that there's a very tight
relationship between aspiration and
responsibility so let's say well the
first question might be do you need to
Aspire to something an answer is well
yes because you have to do something
okay if you just sit there you'll die
you can't just sit there you have to go
act out in the world okay so act towards
what well that's whatever your
aspiration is you have to have a name
okay well what should the aim be well it
should be something worth doing let's
say why do something that you don't feel
is worth doing what do you think's worth
doing well if you watch other people and
you judge when they're doing something
worthwhile you usually judge them
positively if you see that they're
taking responsibility at least for
themselves or do you want to be
completely useless so other people have
to take care of you that's pretty
pathetic and maybe you could get your
act together so you're taking care of
yourself and your family and maybe you
could even do better than that and take
care of yourself and your family and
your community there's lots of ways of
defying the crowd let's say I mean you
could live your life the way that you
want to live it that's a matter of
action
you know and they say actions speak
louder than words and one of the best
things you could possibly be is a
inspirational example so that's not
nothing
um
that's that's something live properly
in your Defiance of the crowd right
make your own course
allow yourself to be guided by your own
genuine principles you don't necessarily
have to advertise that which is in some
sense what you're doing when you when
you're debating because you're taking
the manner in which you act like if
you're an integrated person and you're
articulating that
um but maybe you can't do that because
you don't have the verbal skills well
then the question would be maybe you
should develop some more verbal skills
like I don't know this for sure Dave you
know but but generally it's useful how
do you do that
um
doesn't hurt to read
really doesn't hurt to write you know a
little bit of writing every day
clarifies your thinking you need a value
hierarchy it's inevitable that you have
a value hierarchy
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well structured
and that there should be something of
divine importance at the top I would say
what should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that each
person is of divine value and that the
most appropriate way of interacting with
potential is by embodying and speaking
the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be at
the highest Pinnacle of the value
structure I would say that's what the
logos is
and so
the soul is a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different pathways in in
the choice between different ways of
transforming the potential of the future
into the actuality of the present and it
does that by making ethical Decisions by
choosing between good and evil at each
choice point and to the degree that it
chooses good then it takes the raw
potential of
the future
and it transforms it into the being of
the present that is good and to the
degree that it does that in a manner
that's evil and contaminated by
malevolence and hatred and vengefulness
then it takes a pathway that corrupts
the world and makes things worse and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that and
it's also that active part of the Soul
that's shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character
there's a part of the brain called the
hypothalamus and it's very very very old
we share it with virtually every animal
that has a nervous system it's it's sits
above the spinal cord it's extremely old
evolutionarily speaking and half of it
governs fundamental motivation so
governs hunger for example so if you're
hungry
you posit the existence of something
that will satiate your appetite a peanut
butter sandwich and then you're happy
when you're moving towards the kitchen
and then maybe you get thirsty and the
hypothalamus does that and then maybe
you need to use the washroom and maybe
you're too hot and that the hypothalamus
pops up these little motivational frames
and then emotions modulate your movement
towards the goal that's established by
these fundamental motivations but that's
only half the hypothalamus the other
half is the origin of the dopaminergic
system that mediates exploratory
striving and positive emotion and so the
way our brains are set up way below what
way below the neocortex way way older
than that the default position is if
you're satiated in all the important
dimensions
then you're curious and explore well why
well because you might find new
resources that could be used to
to to uh satiate those fundamental
motivations in the future so that heroic
drive into the unknown is unbelievably
archaic
and then it's regulated by fear and pain
you know so you go into the unknown well
you don't want to die so if you get
damaged you experience pain and you want
to avoid pain so you experience anxiety
these are very fundamental systems a lot
of people don't read because they're
afraid of books the books aren't their
friend so you might want to get a few
books and kind of make them your friend
um you can start with
simpler books you know like fiction
there's lots of good fiction writing for
adolescents and children
it's pretty straightforward you can
start there
if you're interested in philosophy
there's lots of
simple guides like the idiot's guide to
um different topics or a beginner's
guide I read those things all the time
when I'm first investigating a new topic
you know I start with the introductory
material
um and I make time for reading like and
it was that was encouraged in my family
like I always read before I went to
sleep I read
and I I still do that
um somewhat less so because I've become
so distracted by social media
but uh
you set aside a bit of time every day to
read and for me it was always just
before I went to bed I go to bed turn on
the light and read for oh when I was a
kid for hours but
and if you do something every day you do
a lot of it and so I would say well if
you want to read if you want to make
yourself educated just put aside 20
minutes a day to read or 10 you know
some small amount of time that you could
actually steal not two hours because
good luck man it's very unlikely you'll
manage that but 20 minutes a day you
know that's
two hours a week that's 700 hours a year
you know that's
even if you're a slow reader that's a
good number of books and so you make it
a habitual part of your life and you
decide that it's going to be something
that you value you investigate carefully
what resistances you might have to that
idea because you might think well that's
uh pseudo-intellectual or there's
something more productive I could be
doing or I'm intimidated by books or I
hate books because I wasn't good at
reading when I was a kid and was
humiliated because of it or you know
you've got something against
intellectuals or
God there might all sorts of resistances
to picking up a book then you could
listen to audiobooks that's a good way
around that by hooker by crook man
so
you value it you make it a regular part
of your life you practice doing it and
and you you need a higher goal too is
like well why should you read well
it's so that you're more informed and
you can think better why should you be
more informed and think better because
you won't walk blindly into so many pits
you know you'll be able to negotiate
better in your life because you'll be
more
informed and more verbally fluent and
you'll have a better sense of how the
world works and be able to hold your own
in conversations and that'll make you
more confident those are all
unbelievably good reasons to be highly
literate is is an incredibly massive
massive advantage
practical Advantage you know and it
shouldn't be underestimated if you have
a dispute with someone
and it needs to be settled and maybe
they need to change more than you and
that's not always the case because
sometimes the settling requires change
on your part but let's say that they
have to be defeated in some sense
in comparison to you you don't want to
defeat them any more than necessary you
know it's like you don't knock your
opponent to the ground and then jump up
and down on them three or four times in
in Triumph you know you pin them and
then and then let them up
minimal necessary Force because any more
than that just produces a counter
reaction
and I guess the other thing is too is my
motivation when I'm engaged let's say in
these discussions is that I'm not trying
to win the argument
I'm not trying to win
I'm trying to say what I think as
clearly as I can and there is
there might be an element
there might be one of the consequences
of that might be
what appears to be a victory but
the right Victory is the victory for
your ability to articulate what you
believe
and that's what I'm trying to do and so
that's another reason
to stay composed is like well okay
this person is just throwing a curveball
at me it's like all right so
well
I could be thinking well I don't want to
be undermined by that and I don't want
to make a fool of myself and I don't
want to be put on the spot and of course
all those things are true but mostly
what I'm thinking about is okay well now
I've got that question
okay
I want to answer as truthfully as I
possibly can
what do I think about what was just said
and I'm not calculating the outcome
I'm assuming this is a Mark of Faith
right this is the faith that that that
people have talked about
being
something that
has to be manifested necessarily we've
been talking about this since the dawn
of time what's the faith the faith is
that if you say what you believe to be
true then whatever happens is the best
thing that could have happened
and I believe that so that's and I
really believe it
partly because I believe that if you're
deceitful which is the opposite of that
or manipulative or malicious or
malevolent
but maybe primarily manipulative
then what you're acting out is your
belief that deceit will
bring Victory and I just don't believe
that at all I I just I think it's a
Preposterous claim
and so if seek won't bring Victory then
truth is what brings Victory if there is
such a thing as truth and there's
certainly such a thing as deceit so
there must be such a thing as truth
and so
and some of it's just curiosity too it's
like well I'm going to say what I think
and see what happens that's an adventure
you know that's the adventure of your
life really and you don't want to miss
that because
that's what you've got in your life is
for it to be an adventure it's not an
easy Road you know it's a stormy sea and
what you have is the adventure of
contending with God and the waves that's
what you have the way you do that is
with truth
and
then that sort of takes you out of that
immediacy of the conflict whoever it is
that the conflict with whoever it is
that you're talking to
you're trying to Ally yourself with
something that's
deeper and more profound
and more lasting
your life doesn't have meaning without
aspiration or name okay so you need a
hierarchy of values there's got to be
something at the top it's got to be
something important if you don't have
that your life doesn't have any meaning
so if you criticize the hierarchy or
even the ideas of idea of hierarchy you
destroy the idea of aspiration and then
people have nothing
well that's not helpful people are built
for a struggle and they're built for a
weight and you want to take on a heavy
burden voluntarily see if you can put
yourself together see what you can do
out in the world while you're waiting to
die it's an all-in game it better be
worthwhile and so there's a tight
relationship between responsibility and
aspiration and hierarchy and when you
criticize those things you get rid of
the aspiration could you please discuss
Free Will and Sam Harris's and others
ideas of its non-existence well that's a
good complicated question to kick things
off so I want to tell you a little bit
about how to conceptualize Free Will I
think first because it's obvious that we
don't have
infinite free will our our choice our
choices are constrained in all sorts of
ways and I think part of the reason that
there's a
a continual discussion about Free Will
in the philosophical
in the philosophical literatures because
just conceptualizing the issue properly
is extraordinarily difficult so I like
to think about it at least in part the
way that you think about a game you know
if you're playing a game obviously the
game has rules so if it's a chess game
or a basketball game then there are
things that you can do and and things
that you can't do
and but and so it's it's a it's a it's a
closed World in some sense but the fact
that there are things you can't do when
you play a game also seem to open up a
universe of possibilities for things
that you can do so chess obviously
constrains you to a board and to a
certain number of men and to a certain
pattern of rules but the strange thing
is is that when you put in those rules
because rules sound like limits they
sound always like things you can't do
but when you set up a constrained world
like that and you lay out a system of
rules what you do is open up an Infinity
of of a near Infinity of possibilities
same with music You Know music has rules
obviously and and if you follow the
rules then you can make an infinite
variety of music
and so
and so there's a there's a very
interesting Dynamic that's hard to
understand between constraint and
possibility and there's a deep idea
that's associated with that that I read
in some Jewish commentary on on the
biblical stories that I I read a long
time ago
um talking about the relationship
between God and man and the idea was
that God
imagine it being with the classical
attributes of God omniscience
omnipotence and omnipresence all seeing
all knowing and all-powerful what is it
being like that lack
and obviously the answer is nothing
right because
by definition those three traits
provide for absence of limitation but
then that's exactly what's lacking is
limitation and there's some strange
connection between limitation and and I
was saying say limitation
that that's rule governed as I mentioned
before and the opening up of possibility
so
that isn't necessarily the case that now
determine determinism and limitation
aren't exactly the same thing but
they're analogous and they need to be
discussed together okay so now so that's
the first thing is that our whatever our
free choice is it isn't Limited it's or
it's limited it's it's deeply limited
now here's another thing if I take my
arm and I go like this
you see I'll do that again
now you see there's a movement like that
and then my hands stopped just before my
my other hand now
it takes a certain amount of time for
the neural messages to go from my brain
to my arm and back and the time it takes
my hand to go like this and stop is
actually shorter than the time it takes
a message to get to my brain and back so
what that means is that when I
when I plan this movement which is
called a ballistic movement it's called
a ballistic movement because it's like a
bullet once you let it go it's gone
there's no calling it back I've actually
organized the neurological and muscular
sequences that enable that action before
it's implemented I set all that up and
then it's released and the whole thing
Cascades and so
once the action has been released let's
say then I don't really have any free
will because I can't stop it now so so
you think about that it looks like
there's a temporal gradient with regards
to Free Will is that as you look out
into the future maybe perhaps the
farther out you look into the future
um the farther down the road let's say
the more free your choices are but the
closer they get to implementation the
more they become deterministic governed
by standard causal processes and there's
some transition point where they change
from being what we would describe as
choice that we haven't got to free
choice yet but at least to choice
there's some transition point between
that and Ballistic movement you have to
negotiate until you come to the best
solution that can be negotiated which
isn't necessarily a perfect solution but
it might be the best one that can be
done and then you have to stick with it
until the next negotiation and if you
get upset during the negotiations which
you likely will because these are
difficult topics how to divide up
responsibilities in the house and people
get mad because they feel they've been
taken advantage of or aren't being
listened to one of the rules was well
you can leave the discussion but only
until you calm down and then you have to
come back because these things have to
be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or people do them
resentfully because they're sort of
forced by their own orderliness or their
own conscientiousness or or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through you can tell if you've got the
balance between making peace and
speaking the truth right if the
conversation continues and it can be
emotional and will be and can be
difficult because important things have
to be dealt with but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know and you
might have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
maybe sometimes when you're negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer that other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too which I
think is often a very good idea if you
have to make an important decision in
your life it's very useful to tell the
person that you're negotiating with it
look I'm interested in this and it seems
good but I'm not going to agree until I
sleep on it gives you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision if you sleep on it physical
attractiveness is a very complex trait
um it's also for example it's a marker
of health and of course health is a mark
is a prerequisite for Success so
um I you can't take attractiveness as a
unitary Dimension and measure it
sufficiently accurately
wait I should back up on that
no one that I know of has taken physical
attractiveness as a unitary concept
measured it accurately and then pitted
against IQ and the big five to see if it
to what degree it adds incremental
validity to the prediction of long-term
success
but physical but and so I can't give you
a technical answer you know I can say
well in a complex job over the long run
IQ accounts for maybe 20 percent of the
variance in success leaving 80 percent
therefore random events and and the big
five traits and connection networks and
and family background and all those
other things gender perhaps that all the
other things that determine success
physical we know that physical that
people who are physically attractive
though are given the benefit of Doubt by
other people they they benefit from the
positive halo effect and the positive
halo effect is the propensity of people
to assume good things about someone if
there is one outstanding thing about
them that's easily evident that's good
and so if you're if you're if you stand
up straight with your shoulders back so
that's rule 1 and 12 rules for life then
people are going to see you as more
attractive if you're symmetrical you're
more attractive if you're thin but not
too thin you're more attractive
um
well and then there's like good skin and
good teeth and good hair and and all of
those things and proper proportions and
youth and there's a whole slew of things
that that that feed into that if you are
characterized by a plethora of those
features then people are also going to
assume that you're more competent and
more
um and more
more worth having around let's say but
the problem is is that you are
so separating out the attractiveness
from the things the attractiveness are
is correlated with is very hard that's
why you have to do multivariate analysis
that's multi-variable analysis in any
complex social science because a lot of
these traits overlap so but you know you
can you can there's there's some some
things you can do about that postural
adjustment is helpful to work out with
weights that's extraordinarily helpful
that that increases improves your
posture and makes you more confident and
you can dress reasonably well and
intelligently and
um all of those things to to help
yourself capitalize on whatever
attractiveness you can muster you need a
meaning to sustain you through the
vicissitudes of life okay well try to
debate that it's like is life painful
yes is it anxiety provoking yes is it
uncertain yes is it painful Beyond
bearing sometimes yes it's difficult
everyone agrees about that now they
might disagree about how difficult but
that doesn't matter that the Central
Point holds okay
what if you think that's all pointless
well that doesn't seem very helpful okay
so you need a sustaining meaning well
where do you find that
well
you generally find it in responsibility
to yourself and to other people
something that I learned for example
from Jean Piaget he called that an
equilibrated State an equilibrated state
is like a game that everyone wants to
play and so if you set your household up
properly then it's a game that everybody
is participating in voluntarily and
that's going to be predicated on the
desire for peace and the willingness to
speak truth and the ability to take
responsibility so that has to be part of
your higher order moral aim and then
when you're having a difficult
discussion with someone
the discussion is going to be affected
by that higher order moral aim it's not
going to be contaminated to the same
degree by your desire to inflict pain
and attain Victory and you know crush
your opponent and punish them for their
previous sins and
indicate your disappointment things
they've done over the years and all of
that when you're trying to lead people
forward out of the darkness let's say
out of anxiety and depression and
despair and resentment and bitterness
and anger and all of those things
catastrophic
interactions with their family is that
you get them to stop avoiding
confronting the terrible things that are
in front of them right so basically what
you do instead of saying to them you
know those terrible things that are
happening just ignore those and and find
some peace right get your mind away from
it that isn't what you say you say turn
around and look at them even more than
you've been looking at them it's a very
paradoxical advice but of all the things
that have been proven to Aid people's
recovery and movement towards mental
health that's like at the top of the
list voluntary confrontation with what
you are afraid of or or what you despise
even for that matter and so Jung had an
axiom that he derived from The Alchemist
which was instaquilinus invenator which
meant roughly meant
that which you most need will be found
where you least want to look and I was
also his explanation for why people
weren't enlightened because you think
well the California approached
Enlightenment to speak you know kind of
satirically is follow your bliss it's
like well that's easy if that was the
case everyone would be enlightened but
the union approach is no no no you do
what's meaningful and pay attention
follow the truth and it will take you to
the worst place you can imagine and then
maybe there's some chance for
enlightenment
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday
not to who someone else is today and the
reason I wrote that was because I had
this client 10 I'm a clinical
psychologist and I've spent 20 hours a
week for 25 years listening to people
listening to people tell me about their
lives you know and and those people were
people who were just barely hanging on
to the bottom of the world up to people
who were so successful you can hardly
believe it like the entire gamut of
people and and that's been absolutely
fascinating it's like it's like being a
clinical psychologist if you really
listen is like being immersed in a
Dostoevsky novel all the time you know
because it's amazing what people will
tell you if you listen to them they are
people are so interesting if you
actually listen to them because they're
so peculiar like they're like penguins
or rhinoceroses and ostriches they're
unlikely creatures and anyways
um with regards to comparing yourself to
who you were yesterday and not just who
someone else is today
um this old client of mine he was about
85 when he came to see me and he was a
financier and a kind of a mathematical
genius he made these little pendants out
of a mathematical symbol for the most
beautiful mathematical equation that was
ever written he made them out of gold
and he would hand those out and and he
he had studied psychology as a young man
and he introduced me to this concept
that I didn't know about called the
Pareto distribution which see I'd been
taught as a psychologist that most human
characteristics
who are normally distributed right so
most people were average and some people
were extreme that's a pre or a normal
distribution intelligence is like that
and height there's more people of
average height than than very tall or
very short and weight is like that and
lots of things are normally distributed
and psychologists tend to assume that
everything is but it isn't
creative products are distributed in a
Pareto distribution and that's a whole
different thing and it's really
important to know this it's another
fundamental fact the knowledge of which
can sort of transform the way you
conceptualize let's say the political
landscape so here here's an example of
the Pareto distribution huh you know
there's a rule of thumb that if you run
a company that 20 of your employees do
80 of the work or the 20 of your
customers are responsible for eighty
percent of your sales or the 20 of them
are responsible for 80 of the customer
service calls same thing but that's not
exactly the rule the rule is worse than
that the rule is
in a given domain the square root of the
number of people operating in that
domain do half the productive work
so you think well you have 10 employees
three of them do half the work it's like
yeah okay what if you have 100 employees
then 10 of them do half the work what if
you have a thousand employees well then
it's 30 and if it's ten thousand
employees then it's a hundred and this
actually turns out to be a rather
Ironclad rule it it applies across very
very many situations it applies for
example to the mass of stars and the
size of cities so you can see how
Universal it is as a law it's it's
something like those that have more get
more and those that have less get less
that's the Matthew principle right to
those who have everything more will be
given from those who have nothing
everything will be taken away and the
economists sometimes call that the
Matthew principle and so what what that
lays out is a world that's Rife with
inequality so you know you you hear this
idea that I think it's the 85 richest
people in the world have more money than
the bottom two billion that's a Pareto
distribution phenomena and you might say
to hell with capitalism for producing
that it's like sorry you got your
diagnosis wrong it's a natural law it's
no matter what Society you study you get
a Pareto distribution of wealth you get
a predo distribution of number of
Records recorded you get a predo
distribution of number of Songs written
or goals scored like any creative
product has that characteristic and it's
partly because as you start to become
successful let's say people offer you
more and more opportunities and as you
start to fail people move away from you
and you plummet and so
okay so that's rough so what it is what
it means is that there is always a
landscape of inequality and I'm not
saying that we shouldn't do anything
about it although I am saying that we
don't know what to do about it that's
the thing you know because you can
modify the Pareto distribution of wealth
let's say but if you but we don't know
how to do it without maybe disrupting
the system so completely that it
collapses which is what happened in the
Soviet Union for example and in maoist
China they were trying at least in
principle to adjust inequality
but the Cure was far worse than the
disease and the the truth of the matter
is we actually don't know technically
how much inequality there has to be to
generate wealth we can guess and you
could say well there should be less and
you might say well there should be more
if you're left-wing you'd say less and
if they're if you're right-wing you'd
say well we'll just let the inequality
flourish but we do know that it's
inevitable and we also know that we
don't know how to regulate it so there
is inequality what that means is there's
always going to be people around that
are better at something than you are and
the and that's a that's a problem
because you can get jealous and you can
get bitter and you can get resentful and
worse you can get hopeless you know
because you look like look how I have
this this friend of mine he told me
something so funny
um he was he was decrying his his lack
of success in the world and he compared
himself to his roommate and uh he said
you know his roommate his college
roommate was doing much better than he
was and his bloody roommate was Elon
Musk it's like really like it's like oh
you're not doing as well as Elon Musk
well it's not I mean you could see it
would take it rather personally because
they were roommates and everything it
wasn't like he was doing badly like he
was doing pretty damn well it's like I'm
not as good as Elon Musk it's like yeah
well you and like seven billion other
people you know but but I thought it was
instructive because
well because you have to be careful who
you compare yourself to now you can't
just not compare yourself to others to
successful people right because then you
don't have anything to aim at one of the
things I've thought about a fair bit is
the meaning of The Sermon on the Mount
And as far as I can tell it's two-part
wisdom the first is that you should aim
at the highest good that you can imagine
and that would be a good that includes
everyone right so if I wanted what was
good for you say if I generally wanted
it I wanted in a way that was good for
you now and good in the long run and
good for you and your family and your
community and maybe good for me too you
know you could conceive of that as the
desire and I think that's a good
definition of Love is that you actually
want the best you want the best possible
outcome and in the gospels of course
that's extended even to your enemies yes
right is that okay if we're going to
have things good let's have it good
enough for even the people that set
themselves up against me because if the
world was running properly things would
be good for them too and that would be
better and it seems to me that that's a
very good way of looking at things it's
a difficult way of looking at things and
then the second part of The Sermon on
the Mount is something like
having established that as your aim
which is no easy thing by the way right
because you have to be pretty
clear-headed and single-minded to
actually want that to be your aim then
you can concentrate on the day and you
can try telling the truth and you can
Ally so there's truth and love that are
Allied together truth love and attention
it's something like that that are all
Allied together
um with regards to transgressing against
the vulnerable if you're plagued by
boats of depression and anxiety that
does destabilize your identity so
um it's almost by definition but having
said that
look this is when habit and plan
and strategy are so useful so in the
periods of depression that I've had what
system some of them were long and and
and certainly the most unpleasant
experiences of My Life
um you this is when you need a
philosophy let's say that's allied with
your vision and your strategy to sustain
you because what would what would happen
to me is that
I know I have these a vision and I
suppose the vision is of a world that's
better in in
that's less likely to descend into
ideological catastrophe and where people
are more responsible and more awake
and more educated and and and healthier
all of that a vision of a better world
you know a world that's less hellish at
least but also a better world and some
sense of what role I might play in that
and and so that's very motivating like
it's a profound goal to to try to make
things better and you can do that
locally you can do that for yourself you
can do that for your family you can do
that for the broader community and all
of that's worth it man it's worth making
some sacrifices for us we're suffering
for to some degree and then you
decompose that into the day-to-day and
week to week strategies and actions that
you're undertaking the plans and the
activities that you're putting forward
to make that dream a reality to realize
it and then when the depression and
anxiety come along you think
part of it with depression it's like
it's just bloody endurance it's like you
get up and you work through the next
hour you try to stay on track you try to
implement your strategic plans to the
best of your ability and you hope and
you pray that you'll get through it
you know you'll get through it and that
the darkness will recede and you you you
you stay on track you eat even though
you're not hungry you get up even though
you want to stay in bed you interact
with people even though you'd rather be
alone it's the benefit of disciplined
habits
can can sustain you it's like the boat
you're rowing in through a terrible
storm leaks and all and maybe you'll be
overwhelmed but you have the boat and
you can row forward and that's what
you've got and so endurance is a huge
part of it and then I would say with its
anxiety it's the same thing it's like or
very much the same as you're terrified
and and uncertain but you move ahead to
the best of your ability and again you
operate at least to some degree on Hope
and if you haven't got hope then you've
got blind bloody endurance and that's
all motivated by some sense that you're
working towards something that's
worthwhile working to work you know and
and that is well that's your own
long-term well-being to treat yourself
properly it's the stability and
productivity and Harmony and health of
your family that's a huge deal and then
it's whatever benefit you can be to the
community
and if you have to limp along and drag
yourself forward in order to maintain
that pathway then so be it because
it's better than the alternative
higher on the basis of competence
using objective tests and let the cards
fall where they're going to and don't be
afraid to tell people that that's what
you're doing watch your HR department
carefully and make sure that they're not
pushing
diversity inclusivity and Equity
initiatives that they're not requiring
people to take implicit Association
tests that hypothetically reveal their
unconscious bias that they're not doing
seminars on systemic racism and
Prejudice and then they're not making
the assumption that
unequal outcomes let's say in terms of
hiring in the stem fields or in terms of
employment in the stem fields which by
the way are radically overestimated if
you unless you gerrymander what
constitutes the definition of a stem
discipline you just have to you have to
not participate in any of that and you
have to make it known to your peers
which who would be other Silicon Valley
Founders I would presume that you're not
doing any of that you need an ideal
because you have nothing to aim at but
an ideal is a judge and you always fall
short of the ideal so how the hell can
you have the benefits of having an ideal
without having the crushing blow that
goes along with having the judge that
always regards you as insufficient so I
was trying to work that out in the
chapter and this is something I've had
to work out a lot as a clinical
psychologist it's like well
let's say you need a goal but we don't
want to let your distance from the goal
Crush you so you got to set up a goal
and then you got to make the goal break
the goal down into parts so that you can
move towards it you have a fairly High
likelihood of doing it so that's a bit
of practical I wouldn't say advice it's
it's because it's better than advice
it's it's some practical knowledge about
how to go about achieving an aim set a
high aim but differentiate it down so
you know what the next step is and then
make the next step difficult enough so
you have to push yourself past where you
are but but also provide yourself with a
reasonable probability of success it's
also what you do with children right you
you want to push them because they need
to grow up and be more than they are
right but you don't want to crush them
with constant failure so what you do is
aim high and make the goal approx
difficult but proximal I think that the
best approach to ameliorating
inequalities to strengthen the
individual I mean and that's and that's
what I've concentrated on doing like we
have this program uh the self-authoring
suite and there's a component of that
that helps people write an autobiography
and another component that helps them
write an analysis of their personality
write out a plan for the future and
we've used that we've studied the effect
of having people write out a detailed
plan for their future and it's a proper
plan it's like okay look you you get to
have what you want three to five years
down the road you get to have the
friends you want you get to have the
family you want you get to have the
career you want the education you get
you get to take care of yourself
properly you get to withstand
The Temptations of drug and alcohol
abuse and other sorts of impulsive
Pleasures you get to make productive and
meaningful use of your time okay what
does that look like for you write it out
what does it look like just you need a
vision and then you need another vision
of how terrible things could be if you
let all your bad habits get the upper
hand and we've had people do that in an
experimental situation and mostly they
were college students and the
consequences of that there were two
consequences one was General which was
that University students were about 30
percent more likely to stay in
University and got grades there were
about 25 percent better which is a
walloping effect but even more
interestingly and this is the coolest
thing I think that we ever discovered as
in our in our psychological research
we did this research in Holland at the
Erasmus University in Rotterdam at the
Rotterdam School of Management and we
ran business students through the future
authoring program for multiple years so
several thousands of them and we
stratified them by gender and ethnicity
pretty a pretty rough cut men and women
and then
Dutch Nationals and non-western ethnic
minorities okay and so the the
performance was like this the Dutch
women were at the top
then the Dutch man
then the then the non-western ethnic
minority women then the non-western
ethnic minority meant and they were
behind the Dutch women by by they they
showed about an 80 decrement in
performance really quite catastrophic
two years after they did the future
authoring program they were ahead of the
Dutch women
it just blew us away because it was and
it was a perfect indication of the fact
that you can use a psychological
intervention to ameliorate what looks
like a sociological problem don't
recommend any changes
that you wouldn't suffer for if they
failed
how's that
and that's the problem with large-scale
political action it's like well here's
how we should change things it's like
well they changed them it's well it
fails it doesn't bother me it doesn't
hurt me I'm not involved in it it's like
you should be careful when you try to
change things to make sure you suffer
for your own stupidity of course head
down endurance and that'll get you
through bad times that endurance it's
it's it's such an under
represented virtue that ability to
trudge forward unhappily under uh
unfairly burdensome loan is a testament
to character if you can and then it's
something that should be
encouraged and
valued I'm not making the claim that
people who are depressed who can't get
out of bed lack endurance some do and
some don't because depression comes in
very varied uh degrees of intensity and
and you can be laid out completely by
depression
so I'm not trying to make some arbitrary
judgment about who's got endurance and
who hasn't you can't do that from the
outside but I can say that endurance is
one of the tools you have to deal with
chronic discomfort and pain
you know and even if you have chronic
pain it's interesting because it's very
much allied with depression by the way
all of the research on chronic pain back
pain for example indicates in chronic
pain of All Sorts is that
the more you allow your pain to render
you inactive the worst outcome including
exacerbation of the pain and depression
is a pain disorder and so that's very
much worth thinking about too it's like
move forward move forward move forward
you know and if you need to talk to
somebody about what your plan is for the
day or the hour or the week then do that
as well and perhaps you also have to
help get the people around you to help a
bit I need a little bit of help getting
up in the morning I need to have
breakfast made for me so that all I do
when I get up in my in my terrible state
of fog and confusion and terrible
anxiety and depression is I have a
shower because that's what happens first
and then the next thing is I eat and
then that's better you're at least
you're out of bed and moving and that's
that's a start you know
so
and then you endure in Hope
and that's how it is and you do the same
thing when someone in your family is
sick or when you're facing a death all
of that it's like one bloody foot in
front of the other
you can ask yourself that question what
would make this worthwhile I quote ninja
I think in that chapter he said he who
has a why can bear almost any how that's
a lovely line man I mean it's a lovely
line and it's really worth thinking
about so you think well how how do I
manage all this misery and suffering and
futility it's like well I need to figure
out what I would have to do in order to
make that clearly worthwhile and so then
you have your goal and then you think
well I need to move towards that
incrementally because I'm kind of
useless and can only do so much and
maybe not even that and but all I have
to do is be a little bit better than my
my miserable self yesterday
and that'll Propel you forward very
rapidly and and you can succeed at it
which is also really lovely because why
not set yourself up for Success you know
because otherwise you droop around like
a number 10 Lobster and you know that's
just not good you get all Pinchy when
that happens and it's not a good thing
do what is Meaningful not what is
expedient and to view the world as a
place of resources that can be delivered
to you it's in some sense to be
expedient is to take the short-term it's
to take the approach of short-term
gratification something like that yes
self-centered it's materialistic too
well it is materialistic but it's also
it's also it's not optimal and it's it's
not wise and the reason for that is is
that it actually turns out like if we're
going to have If We Had A continuing
relationship I would want to try to do a
little bit more for you than you do for
me and I could do that even purely
selfishly say because if I did a little
bit more for you than you did for me you
would want to keep interacting with me
if you want to have a good relationship
with someone that's one thing you don't
do you open your bloody eyes and if they
do something that you would like them to
do again
then you tell them how much you
appreciated the fact that that happened
and you hope that it replicates you know
you see
that that's if there's one thing you can
take away from tonight's lecture that's
that's an extraordinarily useful thing
to know watch and when people do
something that they should do more of
say look I saw that you did this
specific thing I saw that it took some
effort here's what it meant here's
here's how I observed it it's like keep
that up and man if you love someone you
do that to them that's that's
encouragement that's such a great thing
back to children so I already knew that
I was pretty decent Monster by the time
I had kids and I thought well my kid my
kid's little you know like a baby or
two-year-olds like I'm a horrible
monster and so that there's an uneven
power problem here I better not let that
child do anything that really makes me
angry you know now you hear now and then
you hear about something horrible that
happens I when I was in Boston years ago
I read about a woman who plunged her
two-year-old daughter's arms into
boiling water you think well how in the
world can that happen it's like well you
know
she's probably hungover
she probably just lost her job
she was probably desperate in six
different ways she probably didn't have
any decent disciplinary disciplinary
strategies for children she probably
didn't have anyone helping her she was
bitter and resentful and angry and the
child misbehaved at exactly the wrong
moment and like you're going to be
around your children a lot and so you
might want to have it so that they don't
misbehave at exactly the wrong moment
because all all hell can break loose if
they can and I didn't want that to
happen so and I knew that it was easy
for people to hate their children even
though they mouth the words that they
love them all the time I saw very little
evidence of that many situations and so
one of the things you know you have a
natural affinity for children and even
more maybe a more powerful natural
affinity for your own children so that's
a good start but you don't want to set
them up as an enemy against you you
don't want to allow them to engage in
the kind of hierarchical challenge that
makes you irritable and resentful that's
not a good idea and if the things they
do make you dislike them the probability
that they will make other people people
dislike them is extraordinarily high and
so you can consult your own irritability
and you can say look kid I used to tell
my kids this you know when they were
three or four I'd say look I'm not in a
very good mood and I'm likely to be
unreasonable so it'd be best if you'd go
in your room and play for a while it's
like I like you man you're a great kid
but like get the hell out of here for a
while you know and they were fine with
that we'd trained them already at that
point to be able to go play by
themselves in their room you know which
is something a kid should be able to do
anyways but but you need to know what
sort of monster you are if you're going
to be a good parent and if you think oh
I'm not a monster it's like oh yes you
are you're just an unbelievably
unconscious monster and that's actually
the worst kind so and then the other
thing about that chapter is there's an
idea in it and and it's an idea that I
think is well supported by the relevant
literature which is that your
fundamental job as a parent especially
of a child from zero to four is to make
that child eminently desirable socially
so what you're you're a successful
parent if when your child is four all
sorts of other children want to play
with him or her that's really the that's
like if you want one marker of whether
or not you've been successful that's it
now some children are a lot harder to
get along with than others and some
children have a harder time playing and
so I'm not saying that every parent who
has a child that isn't popular at four
is is at fault for that I'm not saying
that I'm saying the reverse which is you
can be sure that you've been successful
if your child is not popular exactly but
desirable as a playmate and so then you
think well what have you done for your
child well you've opened up the entire
world of children to them so because
they know how to play which is a very
deep knowledge and and it starts to
become inculcated probably at the breast
and certainly in the course of rough and
tumble play at about two years of age
it's a deep embodied knowledge they know
how to play like a good well-trained dog
knows how to play you know you meet a
new dog and you go like this and the dog
goes like this you think oh that dog I
can go like this and it won't bite me
right it knows how to play and a kid
who's awake and alert is just like that
like a well-socialized kit if you know
anything about kids is you can take a
four-year-old and make a little play
gesture at them and they'll smile right
away and start playing just right now
and that's what you want for your kids
and then everywhere they go other kids
like them and will include them in their
Play and play is the way the children
develop and so if other children include
them in their play then the children
develop and the poor kids that don't get
befriended at the age of four with the
literature on this is Crystal Clear if
your child is an outcast at the age of
four the probability that anything can
be done about that is almost zero no
matter what you do and I hate to be so
blunt about that but I know the
literature and that's what the
literature suggests there's a higher
order moral principle that needs to be
brought into the situation and you sort
of described that right at the beginning
of the question because you said well
what partly what you do when you move
from an addicted state from a
psychological perspective is move from a
Viewpoint of the gratification of
immediate desire and and maybe the
accumulation of things as a marker of
success to the notion that no you
actually have a higher purpose and that
higher purpose might involve being of
service that could be of service to
yourself which means you wouldn't be
addicted anymore because that's not a
good way of being of service to yourself
but of service to yourself and the
broader Community however you might
Define that that's a higher order
purpose and it can integrate your
motivations at a level that doesn't
leave you at the whim of impulse that's
the purpose of a higher order motivation
you do what you can to make the things
around you better you better your family
better and then whatever you can manage
in your community
you know
um if you're interested in drug addicted
and the mentally ill no there are
volunteer you could volunteer
you could talk to those people and
listen because then you'd find out what
the hell their problems are and then
you'd have some sense about how they
might be helped you know but that's a
hard thing there's no
helping from above
drug addiction and its combination with
mental illness unbelievably complicated
problems there's no Simple Solutions
so and it isn't even necessarily obvious
that the people that you see who are
homeless and drug addicted and mentally
ill don't want to be helped is that
sometimes they have problems that are so
absolutely overwhelming that they can't
be helped in any real sense you know
like if they're
unmedicated schizophrenic for example
with a drug problem is God it's just
it's just a nightmarish it's a nightmare
of insane complexity because
schizophrenia is very very difficult to
deal with even
with medication because the
medication that helps people who are
schizophrenic also tends to depress
their positive emotion and decrease
their motivation you know so the
medications are generally helpful and
the proper treatment guidelines if
you're schizophrenic generally are stay
with your medication
because
despite the negative consequences of the
medication which aren't trivial
the consequences of not taking it are
worse and that's a real Hobson's choice
right it's a bit of Hell in both
directions
but if you really want to know I would
say
go have some
contact with those people
and listen to them
and learn what the problems are maybe
you could start seeing what might be
helpful it's a really complicated
problem
and it's different than the problem of
helping people who don't want to be
helped because you have to figure out
who it is that doesn't want to be helped
first and you don't want to assume that
just because someone's homeless that
they don't want to be helped
I mean
that doesn't mean that it's easy to
figure out how to help them it's not
easy it's helping people is a very
difficult business and it's a very
dangerous business too because you get
tangled up in ways that you wouldn't
expect and that can be
an occupational hazard let's put it that
way
if you don't allow your children to
engage in dislikable Behavior then
adults will like them because adults
actually like kids you know one of the
things I loved about having little kids
in Montreal I lived in a poor area in
Montreal there's a lot of rough guys
around there and we used to roll our
daughter around in a stroller these
rough guys you know like
God only knows what they were up to
they're rough looking guys you know we'd
roll our daughter by them and they'd
they'd like smile and they'd crouched
down and make little goo faces and you
know they were you I tell you one of the
great things about having little kids is
they bring out the best in other people
you see a whole side of humanity even
among the darker parts of humanity you
see a whole side of them that you
wouldn't normally see and it's lovely
and the thing is if you're good to your
kid in in the real way you can help them
maintain that tremendous attractiveness
that they have as young children and to
respond to adults properly like a puppy
that wags its tail instead of growls and
you know goes for your ankle and then
wherever they go adults welcome them and
teach them things and Pat them on the
head and smile at them genuinely instead
of saying oh my God here comes that
couple with that goddamn brat again you
know which is the horrible that's
horrible thing to do to a child because
then everywhere they go all the good all
the good will is false
you know there's nothing that you can do
to someone that's more terrible than to
put them in a world where all the good
will directed towards them is false
that's a terrible thing you see these
mass shootings all the time and everyone
does the same thing oh how did that
happen why did that happen how can it be
this way it's like well why don't you
read what they said about why they did
it and just assume that that's the
reason and if you go if you go
oh well the Columbine kids
oh yeah it was like oh they must have
been bullied oh yes because you know the
natural response of anyone who's been
bullied is to go arm yourself to the
teeth to plot the destruction of the
entire city I think it was of Detroit to
line your entire High School Avenue with
bombs and then to go and shoot your
classmates that's what happens when
you're bullied it's like no that that's
not what happens when you're bullied
that's a stupid explanation it's shallow
beyond belief and it and it really
emerges only because people don't want
to contend with the real issue and the
Columbine kids while they were
contending with the real issue you know
they basically said quite forthrightly
that in their own arrogant estimation
being itself was corrupt and unnecessary
and it would be best if it was
eradicated in the most brutal possible
way as fast as possible and you get to
places like that if you dwell on Revenge
for three or four years in your mom's
basement you know you can go to very
dark places I took what I learned about
what happened in the second world war
seriously
it's like wow we can be really bad
we should do something about that
like that was unacceptable
well was it or not but how unacceptable
was it change your life unacceptable
better be
if you want it not to happen again
and it's not like it the next time it
happens
will make the previous time look like a
picnic
we're way more powerful than we were
you know when we're getting to the point
of something Jung talked about
especially near the end of his life
we're getting so powerful that each
individual is now a force of almost
unimaginable destructive power if they
so choose to be
and that's just going to
that power is going to continue to
increase
and what that means is that the degree
to which each of us has our act together
is going to be something upon which the
world increasingly Depends for its
maintenance
that's why humility is always stressed
in in great religious Traditions
humility is precisely that it's like you
have to look at why you're not so good
yeah and and you know that that has to
break down your pride to some degree and
your arrogance is like well that's great
because if you break down your pride and
your arrogance then you're primed to
learn and you can solve your problems so
there's nothing in that it's a bit
crushing to begin with because you might
think oh my God there's really a lot of
things wrong with me yeah but at least
then you're on the on the road to fixing
them I just found out I'm having a girl
congratulations what can I do to raise
her to think for herself
and not fall into the modes of thinking
proposed by popular culture well you can
let her think for herself when she's a
kid you know what you do is so that she
practices doing that and so that means
to
consciously encourage as much autonomy
as possible so
how do you do that well let's say she's
a little kid she's three and she starts
to get interested in clothing so you lay
clothing out on the bed and you say well
you can wear this or you can wear this
you let her make autonomous decisions
you know with kids
you don't want to let them choose from
an infinite menu you want to give them a
constrained menu but what you want to do
with your daughter
is allow her to make as many decisions
as she can possibly make as early as
possible
you know and that doesn't mean that
children always know what's best for
themselves or any nonsense like that it
just means that you're going to
encourage her autonomy to every
in every
measure that you can manage that means
you're going to have to be brave and
allow her to subject herself to a
certain number of risks
so
you you you raise her to think for
herself by letting her think for herself
and and that can start that can start
quite early
um I would say when she's a teenager
she's going to fall into the modes of
thinking proposed by popular culture
because that's part of being
enculturated and socialized it's
virtually inevitable and it's even
somewhat desirable but what you hope is
that you've
you've encouraged the capacity for
autonomous thinking to a sufficient
degree that it's likely to integrate
with that more intense teenage
socialization and then re-emerge so you
get someone who comes out the other side
as an autonomous individual and that
works with boys and girls so so you know
let's I guess you do what Geppetto did
in Pinocchio is the first thing you
decide is well you don't want to raise a
puppet
you know you want to raise an autonomous
person and and then you think through
what does it mean to be an autonomous
person what sort of person do you want
your child to be what
what sort of person do you want to
encourage your child to be and then
having having
established that vision in mind that's
going to guide your choices but at least
you're making the right choices you
don't want someone who's dependent and
whiny and cringy and and
more frightened than they need to be and
Martyr martyr like and vengeful and
malicious and manipulative and
mendacious all of those things you want
someone who can
make their own judgments and you can ask
kids what they think pretty damn early
like you have to be careful and not push
them beyond their capacity but
if you know your child you'll be able to
see what level of decision making
they're capable of engaging in and then
you would encourage them to mature as
rapidly as they can
you know and that also means that you
have to not allow yourself to fall too
in love with the
dependent and needy creature that your
infant will be to fulfill your own
emotional needs
you want to detach and and encourage to
mature as rapidly and as comprehensively
as possible and that will work
you know and
some of that some of that is
negotiation with your child you find out
what they think it's like what do you
think about this
what do you think about who should do
the work in the house how should we
split it up like they can be engaged in
the decision-making process as a very
early age
and and part of that's
that encouragement is
going to be reflected in your implicit
attitude that the child is a real person
who's capable of
imposing their will in a realistic sense
in the world on the world and doing that
in a confident and confident manner how
do I stop ruminating these thoughts are
recurring and relate to every and any
embarrassing moment I have ever had
during my lifetime I'm a 76 year old
woman well oh well here's something you
could try
write down everything that you're
ruminating about I know that seems
counterproductive but like see
ruminations come up accidentally
involuntarily unconsciously
whereas if you write down everything
that you're ruminating about you're
facing them voluntarily so I would say
well open up a journal or Word document
whatever and write down every time you
ruminates about something write it down
and write down every rumination you can
remember exhaustively write them all
down
that would be the first thing and the
second thing is standard behavioral
therapy practice the second thing the
next thing would be write down why you
think they happened
so that you get a good causal account
and then write down well what you might
have done about them then but more
importantly what you could do about them
in the future to avoid that because it
doesn't matter that something
embarrassing happened to you once what
matters is
whether or not you're likely to repeat
it in the future but my suspicions are
that even if you just
you could just start simply
write down every ruminating ruminating
thought that you have voluntarily and
and think about them in detail and write
them down in detail get every little
word down and
then you have that document and then
when you have a thought and start to
ruminate on it
um then
sit down later after the ruminating
thought goes away and bring it to mind
voluntarily
so every time you have a thought you
don't want to have
later practice having that thought on
purpose and try that for about a month
and see what happens because it's often
the case that if you start thinking
about
the thoughts you're ruminating on
consciously and confront them
voluntarily that they will start to go
away so one of the things that happens
in the Mesopotamian creation myth the
enumelis is that the gods are created
they're they're The Offspring of chaos
that's a good way of thinking about it
and they become very careless and they
destroy their category system they
destroy their father essentially and
Chaos comes flooding back
and that's what happens to people who
aren't looking at things and delimiting
them properly they become apocalyptic
and do them in but sometimes in uh
mythology there is the positive
um
confronting of the god EG Prometheus so
sometimes we need to still steal the
fire sometimes we need to challenge
these orthodoxies don't we yes
absolutely I mean part part of the well
part of the death that you're describing
is actually the confrontation with a
form of tyrant like your previously
addicted self was the Tyrant over your
emergent self yes and so it's an
internal Tyrant and you said it was
predicated on a false value system
that's a false set of gods essentially
and so you had to confront that that is
a kind of death if you're seriously
suicidal
and you can tell if you are if you have
a plan like a plan that you've that
you've played out in fantasy multiple
times if you know how you would do it
and when and where and if you fantasize
about the aftermath like if that's a
well-developed plan then you should go
talk to someone you should talk to
someone professional you should let a
friend know you should let a family
member know like you need to do that
you're at risk you're in danger under
those circumstances
there's a part of the brain called the
hypothalamus and it's very very very
very old we share it with virtually
every animal that has a nervous system
it's it's sits above the spinal cord
it's extremely old evolutionarily
speaking and half of it governs
fundamental motivation so governs hunger
for example so if you're hungry
you posit the existence of something
that will satiate your appetite a peanut
butter sandwich and then you're happy
when you're moving towards the kitchen
and then maybe you get thirsty and the
hypothalamus does that and then maybe
you need to use the washroom and maybe
you're too hot and that the hypothalamus
pops up these little motivational frames
and then emotions modulate your movement
towards the goal that's established by
these fundamental motivations but that's
only half the hypothalamus the other
half is the origin of the dopaminergic
system that mediates exploratory
striving and positive emotion and so the
way our brains are set up way below what
way below the neocortex way way older
than that the default position is if
you're satiated in all the important
dimensions
then you're curious and explore well why
well because you might find new
resources that could be used to
to to uh satiate those fundamental
motivations in the future so that heroic
drive into the unknown is unbelievably
archaic
and then it's regulated by fear and pain
you know so you go into the unknown well
you don't want to die so if you get
damaged you experience pain and you want
to avoid pain so you experience anxiety
this is a very fundamental systems and
they are reflected in our narratives
that's essentially as far as I can tell
why
the dragon Hoards treasure everywhere
the dragon is an amalgam of predatory
stimuli and Fire
which is a destructive force but also
very useful so dragon is something like
predatory destructive entity you might
say well is that real it's like well
yeah but it's a meta-category it's like
there are lions and Raptors and
um lizards let's say uh 60 million years
ago when we were still in trees
the idea that there's a meta Predator is
a great idea a meta Predator is what all
predators share in common
that's a dragon well what should you do
with a dragon
well avoid it that's one answer another
answer is burn it out of its layer so
that it doesn't have baby dragons the
and the uh an even more sophisticated
answer is well
confront it
you can feed your family with the body
of a dragon
it's treasure
the soul is also the center of the world
which is a frightening proposition and
not one that's easily comprehensible
archipelago is particularly enlightening
in this regard
um
because he insisted that it was a pre
conception of our judeo-christian
heritage that each person was the center
of the cosmos and you can think of that
as
a center of Consciousness right a center
from which being itself is not only
reflected but also generated and it was
Souls knitson's
belief and dostoevsky's as well and I
think Jung would have been in accordance
with this and Nietzsche as well
for that matter that
in some manner that we don't fathom
because we don't understand the
structure of the world very well the
outcome of
the world is dependent on our choices
and and equally on all of our choices
and it I don't understand I know that's
I know that to be true or feel that to
be true
it's it's part of the doctrine that each
person is of intrinsic and equal worth
the part of that Doctrine is that each
person is has intrinsic and equal
responsibility and that we're each
capable of generating a fair bit of hell
around us and for other people but also
capable of generating a tremendous
amount of good and that the fate of the
world as it careens through
eternity is actually a consequence of
the ethical decisions of each of us it's
a terrifying idea it's no wonder people
flee from it into Hedonism let's say and
and ideology because it's very
frightening
possibility that the choices that you
make day to day
or fail to make
have this profound and Lasting effect on
the structure of reality but I don't
really see any way out of that
conclusion I've watched the audiences
very carefully and listen to them
to see what resonates and and what
doesn't and
I think the
the the the basic argument that I've
been laying out
is that
well we all have difficult lives you
know that life is characterized in in
large part by suffering there's an
inevitable element of suffering in life
I mean obviously that symbolized in
Christianity by the crucifixion which is
a very harsh symbol and
um and not only is life sorrowful in
part but it's also touched by
malevolence and malevolence of each of
us and the malevolence of our social
Creations our societies and even in some
sense the kind of blind malevolence of
Nature and it's a demanding
occupation to to exist as a human being
and you need
something
to sustain yourself through that it's
not optional because the the price of
existence is so high that without that
sustaining meaning
it it it corrupts you it it embitters
you and and once you're embittered
things go downhill rapidly you get
vengeful and and you get angry and and
you get destructive and there's really
no limit to that and I've been
suggesting to people that the sustaining
meaning that they can find in their life
isn't to be found through happiness
let's say because happiness doesn't work
when you're not happy when when when
when things have gone badly for you for
for even for accidental reasons but you
can find sustaining meaning and
responsibility
and you can take responsibility
for yourself
you can do that and if you take
responsibility for yourself you treat
yourself as if you're someone that's
worthy of
care and and discipline and then that
has nothing to do with being soft on
yourself
or the pursuit of pleasure or any of
those things you can take responsibility
for yourself and that works and then if
you do that properly you can take
responsibility for your family and then
if you do that properly you can take
responsibility for your community and
you can continue to
burden yourself voluntarily let's say
with with a greater and greater range of
existential challenges and all that that
does is make more and more and more of
you
and that works as an antidote to the
catastrophe of life
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for Jordan
Peterson's 12 rules to change your life
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the first rule
which is kind of a comical rule is stand
up straight with your shoulders back and
it's a meditation among other things on
the habits of lobsters I read some
papers on lobsters